sa part
non et prendre s'il veut me prendre 1
200 p te plaît j'ai oublié de la prendre
au passage merci mon fab et ben voilà le
la petite bascule ada qui part c'est la
12e partie
alors est-ce que ça a marché je l'espère
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai pas des
caméras
on n'a pas les calmes
j'espère que ça joue aujourd'hui
au pire on n'aura pas les calmes on
n'aura pas les calmes c'est pas non plus
gravissime
il n'y a pas non plus mort d'homme
à il ya une cam
on commence fable je te propose par
défaut n'a qu'à quand même parce que ça
pourrait être une turbo nul et et en
plus c'est quand même une partie qui a
une certaine importance pour le tournoi
a vu que c'est le le leader contre le
troisième ouais complètement fou
d'accord si la partie à mon avis qu'il
faut suivre en priorité alors cette fois
duré cinq minutes mais il faut bien la
suivre et oui et oui fab pragmatique
fabas en chemise fargo beau gosse fab
fap qui est là exactement
femmes en grande forme j'ai pas dormi en
plus j'ai bossé la pause ah ouais
fond à fond et non moi j'ai j'ai fait
une semi fiesta et beaucoup de portes
qui claquent et aujourd'hui c'est fou
les gens qui m'ont réveillé oui j'ai été
ban de discours est ce que tu peux me
débats non enfin laissez moi vivre quoi
preuve que non écrivez au mono les
frérots hikaru qui sait que ça va être
nul nous on sait tout le monde le sait
en fait il car au regard est vif et son
petit sourire
c'est comment déjà 22 nuls
e
celle qui fait nul fort c'est là qu'ils
adorent elle marche comment dirais je
crois que c'est des 4 way et des six
ouais de ouais j'avais les baies 5 à 4
ouais et des 4es vous bouffe ouais des
six vrai ouf willam rabbani gestation
d'un mot car tu peux pas de monsieur
système des 4 je pense que ça va être ça
la partie mont fab à ce serait
extraordinaire à l'epo à les dépôts
alors on va t'il va faire tout re 1
prétendre prendre l'aventage au nom au
que non mesdames et messieurs c'est
peut-être la formation du jour les
candidats la tête du tournoi les échecs
toujours plus passionnant fab on en
arrive à un level de suspense quand même
un shérif il est parti aussi à la chine
ce qui tourne chaises tournantes veste
bleue contre veste bleue hausse a failli
faire un 360 degrés fab et ça c'est rare
à ce niveau de la compétition
elle a l'air d'être extraordinaire sept
partis partis 12,1 partie 12 fab abbaoui
12 et alors nous et on est vraiment sur
le genre de parties qu'on aime en
dommage qu'on ne suivent pas que cette
partie aujourd'hui un ça aurait pu être
une journée des tchèques extraordinaire
ah ouais aulas et c'est ce qu'on aime
ah c'est vraiment passionnant à suivre
on arrive parfois à des à des niveaux
au suspense insoutenable
insoutenable
ah ouais non c'est vraiment quelque
chose on voit deux chaises vides et
photographes qui s'en donnent à coeur
joie de belles images parce que c'est le
tour de laisser le tour de l'espagne est
aussi le tour de l'espagne c'est ses
candidats avec avec des sponsors qui
doivent qui doivent être aux anges la
ville de madrid évidemment qu'ils valent
fays de tel de tel parti el pais ça veut
dire quoi sert la paix ou le pays le
pays mais jours sombres la fidh
évidemment chess comme la famille
scheinberg ils sont tous là
si si la famille
ça va être sarah clic
ça va cliquer pour les peaux cavaliers
des six est ce qu'il envoie le des prend
1,5 alors il est pas sûr il n'a pas
décidé ce matin encore s'y faisait nul
il n'a pas dû décider il va se décider
là maintenant sur l'échiquier
décision cornélienne famille-là qu'un
point et demi d'avancé sur le premier
poursuivant et cette avance pourrait se
réduire comme peau de chagrin
aux
épaules ouais une épaule
est reparti c'est une épaule contre
épaule
portant des photos 1 l'as de vence ce
moment il prend 1,5
naka qui revient il s'assied sur le
fauteuil le fauteuil qui tient pour le
moment sous le poids des deux
gladiateurs cavaliers pourront esquive
envoyé le pion à 4
way pièces de moins pour les peaux il
joue à l enferme le cavaly lecavalier
qui revient en d4 fabien qui avait tout
prévu
il lit dans le marc de café fab c'est
pas possible
c'est scénographe abuse même nom sera
fabuleux en fait bah oui et il prend des
quatre qui les prend des cadres dame
prend des 4
je pense que si ça fait nul comme ça
après autant d'émotions va peut-être
s'accorder une petite pause afin d'y
aller
pour souffler des 5 alors là si monsieur
si voix la prise en passant ce serait
quand même très bien joué il hésite un
et peut-être qu'il a oublié cette prise
écart ou quand même lui aussi dubitatif
népotique y réfléchir un petit peu
il la connaît pas cette position c'est
peut-être la première fois qu'il la voit
on le sent en cif et il le fait il a
pris le pion sur une case où il était
pas
et dame prend des six les changes de
dames proposer un petit échec quant à
eux quatre attention il y avait un piège
sur fou aussi savait dame prend bessette
il va replacer la tam en déca
probablement
et wittes ap mike arroub servian d66 se
regardent en chiens de faïence
ils notent bien les coups en attention
ne pas faire une erreur de notation ça
pourrait coûter cher à bien faisait
trois fois au sida me quatre dames 6
d'amd 4
et hikaru qui après dam des sites va
pouvoir demander là nul non ils vont
peut-être le faire plus de trois fois
histoire d'être bien sûr
la vitre qui appelle la vitre allez les
arbitres hikaru qui rigole c'est pas
drôle
ap ap ap ap ap ap il arrête il arrête le
temps illégal il arrête le temps
éliminatoires
disqualifié et la rabbit qui vient qui
va vérifier l'armée tripoli au salon
elle accepte ces accès gratuit pros
quand elle va vérifier la balle bien que
oui fable havard qui est demandé alors
si jamais l'annuler terrain il pourrait
accepter
extraordinaire duels dont les robes bien
vieux monde mayroy les dames à
l'innocence de chiché magnifique
extraordinaire parti les amis vous
n'avez rien raté
et oui huit minutes de jeu aujourd'hui
pour pour le leader
suspense intenable hikaru qui va faire
une belle vidéo à mon avis d'analystes
de cette partie
aouedj en sera
menée pour machines c'est vraiment ce
genre de contenu dans la fin de du
tournoi principal qui va nous permettre
un rebond de hype et de présenter le jeu
on voit vraiment la beauté
ici ouais c'est colossal c'est colossal
ce qui se passe
est née peau qui va qui va repartir
grande partie encore une fois
grande part fabien annoncé en fait on
savait que ce serait cette nuit en plus
on la connaissait
bon voilà
sa vie fond tout le temps dans les
parties au niveau il n'y a rien à dire
on l'a vu à maintes et maintes reprise
c'est une manière d'arranger une nulle a
pas vraiment
pas été obligée ouais
ok bazire voir holding
rapporte qu' un peu déplacé la chaise
quand même ils auraient voulu avoir la
même alors ding
avec les blancs contre raj à
voile a dit me mo
ça on l'a vu à maintes et maintes
reprises journée torrent celle là
exactement alors j'aurai d'un peu les
partis de la base des cuatro
109 points de 8,2 à je ne comprends pas
bien s'ils allaient noir c'est normal
enfin pourquoi ils devraient risquer il
peut pas faire il peut pas faire
autrement en fait c'est juste comme ça
bon les gars mais c'est beau un
extraordinaire spectacle
écoute c'est relativement rare là ce
qu'on a sous les chic chocs ou qu'ils
avaient les a si c'est pas trop trop
trop jouer on voit plus du c6 et qui
allaient plus verte 17 des choses comme
ça et donc qu'elle est assise pour jouer
que ces cinq choix quand eto'o en a
parlé c'est pour ça que je connais et a
dit que c'était pas qu'on sait quand je
crois à froid 6 oui pas les parties
récente a pas du tout je sois en train
de suivre une partie
v7 popov de 2010 par email ah oui ça
doit quand même bien joué
c'était une belle nul quand même bien ça
va enjouaillez en faire quatre comme ça
or et les autres ont déjà pu minutes de
jeu c'est terrible d abord je vais
devoir dépenser 5 pour pas pour jouer la
structure quand on demande juste et ce
qu'ils envisagent de changer les règles
au championnat du monde alors voilà
apparemment ils voudraient nous prendre
nos règles veulent faire un match en
trois sets
mais on sait pas quand ils vont compter
des points en fait on sait rien bree va
être capable de même raté ça mais un
mais c'est marrant on est les seuls à le
faire pour le moment serait beau que je
sais qu'ils auraient piqué l'idée mais
laurent sûr il aurait pas tout seul non
non ça c'est sûr que s'ils le font c'est
qu'ils ont piqué l'idée à 100% en fait
déjà sans jamais rien proposer
surtout pas donner un petit billet pour
organiser rien du tout venant
mais bon après on s'inspire des
meilleures
c'est qui qu'a issam apparemment séné
pau qui a dit que la fidl avait fait un
mail dans ce sens n'ont rien mais
bizarre lui juge blizzard n'a pas trop
compris ils veulent jouer ans est lui
dit qu'il aime bien le snooker
c'est une bonne nouvelle vient way est
peut-être un moment donné faut vraiment
qu'ils contactent les gens qui ont
inventé le truc pour pas qu'ils le
pourrissant fait enfin ce n'est pas
juste en amont et appelle les gens qui
rentrent et le système à qui tu l'as
pris et qui leur demande de concevoir
shoot commencé à marcher comment de
faire un système intéressant pour un
match championnat du monde c'est quand
même
sa part logique parce qu'il vit
comprennent peut-être pas l'essence de
trucs le baril mais ils peuvent pas en
fait fin j'aï comprennent rien donc
en vrai c'est pas impossible qu'ils
étaient vraiment volé l'idée ça m'est
arrivé à peu près au même niveau mais
non mais c'est pas que c'est pas
impossible c'est que c'est que c'est
quasiment sûr en fait on est les seuls à
le faire et c'est un copier coller de ce
qu'ont fait donc c'est sûr en fait
de bons temps mieux enfin en fait non
mais c'est pas une bonne idée
mais faudra pas long pour rire surtout
qu'au pied du tennis pas sur la fille de
regarde bitstream bon c'est quand même
la deuxième chaîne au monde c'est
quasiment sûr qu'ils connaissent en fait
c'est même pas quasiment sûr c'est 100%
sûr
enfin si tu connais quand même la
deuxième plus grande chaîne au monde de
ton jeu quoi fin c'est obligatoire en
fait enfin jarlot tennis à toi tu es
comme ça depuis toujours en fait
l'aspect sentant la fidh a jamais pris
le truc là 7 comme france depuis
quelques mois ici et là le hasard non
c'est grâce au tennis et mais ce sera un
point de fusion ont toujours te dire ça
de façon
mais en fait c'est ennuyeux c'est luce
c'est dommage de pas ils sont capables
de courir le truc en fait ne pas
comprendre l'essence du truc
peu importe
pour dire dans la patrie par
correspondance et blanc avaient rockets
tranquille ou
peut-être b4 peut être un coup
tordu de fer foulée 2
et or d1 et je sais pas quoi après faut
regarder si tu as la 5 qui casse la
structure c'est une aura des quatre
rapide enfin moi j'en sais rien faut
réfléchir
met donc en gros la structure très
mauvaise point noir mais en compensation
évidemment ils ont la paire de fou ce
qui n'est pas rien et donc ils veulent
eux s'activent et il peut voir la petite
percée des quatre à un moment un petit à
5 x 6 ça peut partir dans la colonne b
pour la tour en faisant des trucs au
québec a joué par dick donc vraiment la
nouveauté nouveauté pour le coup
puisque par correspondance ce que je
disais d'aveiro qu'est
donc première fois que la position et
dans la pratique et os qui recule le
fonds gérant b mais
priori toutes les replis sont corrects
faut des 6 ou b6 sa réponse tu
considères que tu peux jouer des 4 ou si
tu considères tu peux pas si je peux pas
faut plutôt aller en d6 pour geler les
taxes je conserve tu vas réussir à jouer
des quatre plus talent b6 je pense qu'on
peut avec des quatre oui mais je dis
renforcer la question
après bassiste n2 eminem et dr en d6
aussi c'est que j'ai avec d'amd si c'est
fou c'est cette
t'as pas besoin de permanents avec
assise celui qui a déjà un pion dessus
donc même en allant b6 on dit pas non à
la tht à calais le droit d'y croire
encore joué cette nuit sur czech comme
va m je sais pas on ne va pas on n'a pas
de chéquier
parler de la phrase de kramnik permet
droit d'être franchie roja une très
mauvaise compréhension des échecs il a
probablement talentueux calcule bien et
sa conversion du la boiteuse bah en fait
le problème c'est que tu coach quelqu'un
pendant six mois tu peux pas dire du mal
après que tu viens de le coacher il fait
son pire tournoi depuis trois ans et tu
lui chie dessus dans les médias donc en
gros la question que je pose c'est est
ce que le problème c'est fear ouja qui
joue mal ce tournoi et ça arrive à
n'importe qui à 19 ans de rater un
tournant une grande échéance ou est-ce
que c'est son coach qui vient lui
cracher dessus dans les médias enfin je
sais pas moi en fait c'est le coach que
je trouve dégueulasse dans cette
situation ou alors dans l'histoire s'est
mal finie elle le coach leonardo su je
sais pas mais en fait oui mais c'était
enfin normalement plus personne ne doit
jamais de front dans cette fin tu chies
sur quelqu'un que tu a entraîné baby
enfin là peut-être si l'objectif mais
quoi qu'il en soit et trop parties
prenantes au projet produits chier
dessus comme ça puis il vient lui en
suisse où les jours dans les médias date
est parti à 2300 je suis comprend rien
aux échecs enfin toi t'as jamais gagner
les candidats est a fait des petites
magouilles pour jouer un match au
championnat du monde fin joueur au bout
d'un moment non mais je veux dire
c'est enfin je trouve ça très petit sa
part oui là et il pourrait juste ne rien
de faire dire kuimba ira de son tournoi
qui a des explications mais que enfin tu
peux trouver une manière élégante de
répondre sans rien dire et sans qu'on
leur a baissé plus que ça
by
rémi saillard et c'est souvent de faire
déclaration une heure non mais c'est une
chose qui fait des déclarations lunaire
sur toit jantes à paris sur les parties
des autres mais en fait là tu es partie
prenante fin je vais garder coûte se
tourne
donc peut-être une autre déclaration à
faire c'est kramnik un si mauvais coach
qu'il est incapable d'enseigner la
compréhension stratégique du jeu
d'échecs jamais vu un tel coach fin je
sais pas c'est je trouve ça très moche
en fait
parce qu'en fait il a régressé à son
contact non mais là il ferme tombent
après tout il apparaît quand même
l'équipe de ligue 1 ils sont deuxièmes
tu viens tu les coaches mais si tu finis
tu fini huitième qu'en perdant 13
matches sur 14 et unième ils ont
vraiment employer une mauvaise stratégie
pendant les 14 8 championnat
mais ses besoins fait non mais je ça me
dépasse en fait et pourquoi chemin mais
c'est pas que je n'aime pas mais le gars
fin j'étais coach d'un truc c'est une
question d'aimer krainik ou pas mais
t'es quoi jean truc c'est le truc seras
tu es tu chies sur le truc dans les
médias tous les jours vraiment ce genre
ne veut pas de titulaire c'est un quidam
il faisait la ccl lunaire en fait
d'être cramique le pense vraiment ça
c'est autre chose et donc je ne sais pas
s'il veut arriver des comptes il le
pense vraiment mais quoi qu'il en soit
il
tu peux le faire comprendre sans le dire
comme ça quoi qu'il en soit
ben c'est pas cool enfin j'ai pas c'est
non mais tu peux dire ça de n'importe
quel autre joueur voûté pas partie
prenante mais là en fait c'est toi en
fait
donc tu peux dire on a complètement raté
notre préparation machin j'ai pas
compris les faiblesses de fil rouge à
j'ai pas réussi à lui apporter ce qui
lui manquait pour ses candidats en fait
tu peux dire entre guillemets ses
carences et que toi t'as pas pu lui
apporter ou quoi mais fait justin la
cccc lunaire retourne faire ton
programme cyrus en russie et nous nous
emmerde pas faim quel joueur de talent
il a sorti la russie depuis qu'il allait
budget pharaonique
non mais est ce que les budgets
pharaoniques c'est pour faire un top
mondial je te parle de top 2 3 mondial
là depuis les dix ans qu'il a l'argent
du gouvernement russe pour pour sortir
un talent je sais pas moi non mais c'est
la question que fait un genre où dans le
monde ses fins
je sais pas ça commence à sortir les
dossiers du passé mais n'y a pas du
passif n'est pas dupe à sucre identité
j'espère juste que dans le rôle de coach
n'a rien fait encore et points et là tu
es partie prenante
enfin bon peu importe
sortir un talent c'est tout un programme
surtout du loto je sais pas en union
soviétique il y avait pas mal en fait de
grandes et des fans et ça c'est du loto
tiens regarde kasparov talent petrossian
en bout de vignard of même rate ça on va
kramnik bon rosé vite sous les pommiers
à chier pour maintenant savent à quoi
ils ont pourtant quand c'est lui à la
tête il ya plus personne non mais c'est
étonnant en fait quelqu'un d'aussi
compétent
la compétition mondiale était moins
forte
je suis pas sûr a laissé magnifique en
fait c'est fatah toujours une excuse en
fait c'est
mais bon on en reparlera dans quatre
cinq ans quand ali reza aura gagné les
candidats et sera devenu champion du
monde légitimement
bâton pour en reparler
c'est grâce à ma phrase je les piqués au
vif l'express
autrefois les gens étaient très belle
c'est kevin ses talents sa
chronique n'a jamais connu est il le bon
coach pour centrer c'était avant la
décla que tu disais ça de quoi tu parles
en fait
enfin mon
gens racontent n'importe quoi et c'est
toujours pareil en fait
racing quo donc c'était des questions
j'avais sur b4 à désenclaver cette
barre d'options possibles qui était
probablement l'idée un tour pourraient
changer un pion à contre un pion b et
c'est logique et sur b 5 qui veut faire
à 6 j'imagine et harceler le
périscolaire tu peux te dire je fais à 5
à 6 c b6 un peu fou georges élections
ben je vous reparle fou c'est vrai je
pensais qu'on aurait jamais fait en fait
ouais mon problème c'est que je crois
que les gars ont bien ri non mais je
n'aurais pas fait en fait
ça fait deux semaines j'entends dire
depuis le début que kramnik n'est pas
l'homme de la situation je suis cohérent
qui co hasard non mais j'ai refait deux
semaines je ne sais pas l'homme de la
situation l'a dit avant le tournoi il
rate le tournoi on continue à le dire
enfin on est cohérent fait où est le
problème
il se trouve que le scénario du toit
nous donne raison et sans buck ramener
qu'il vaut mieux pas qui disent ça de
son poulain
s'est dit que c'est ce qu'on pensait
mais on n'en n'était pas sûre il aurait
très bien pu réussir légère c'est
cohérent
on sait pas quoi
très bien pu marcher on pouvait tout à
fait se tromper ça c'était possible
enfin autant il gagnait les candidats et
on s'était trompé c'est tout ce qu'on
souhaitait
pas me soir a pu être prometteur
d'ailleurs c'était pas mécaniquement une
idée débile mais ça vraiment pas marché
bon j geof c'est pas mal ses positions
je ne sais pas je n'aime pas trop les
blancs
ouais il ya quand même des arguments à
faire valoir aussi le fou en b2
mais non mais ça va pas être non mais
oui ça me ça m'inspire pas plus que le
socle qui ont isolé s'il a un peu parlé
avec vlad avant la partie ça peut le
faire
j'aime bien c'est parce qu'en fait c'est
ta put option b 4 le fois ci devait être
hyper chiant
du coup à le blé 5 à 6 v6 sais pas si
cons et c'est vrai que les blancs il
faut aussi peut-être auquel laisser
gagner b4 et de venger leurs bêtes sont
là totalement liquide et l'échiquier que
robinho nul je crois que ça est très
tranquille pour filles pour radjabov
cette partie
on va voir ce n'est pas fait encore mais
oui c'est le scénario qu'on attend
c'est juste un petit tour sur les autres
partis de façon c'est un après les
autres partis ont aucun enjeu est mal
aux quinze jours juste pour voir
rapporte car voilà on va vraiment rester
sur la partie digne
c'est anti berlinoise ok on va voir de
façon caruana je suis pas sûre et
quoique là encore la deuxième place
oui mais non est quoi et duda nous
avions juste voir l'ouverture c'est un
peu normal ou pas
montré assez montré quoi ça je connais
bien mais ici je me rappelle jamais ce
qu'il faut faire en vrai c'est la
position que je bloque à chaque fois du
coup je suis intéressé reste seul te
faire f 4 5 en gros et quand tu vas
faire f 4 fou des quatre échecs roi
atteinte aura plus tg4
mais en fait tu vas l'avoir sans l'avoir
parce qu'il va pouvoir te faire un truc
comme dames 2 et teichmann cavalli a en
gros juste pour montrer en fait deux
bases
quand tu fais ça et cal pions h2 quand
ils font h3 tu as encore d'un match 4 la
patronne bastia d'un match 4 matches
mais tu peux faire dameuse
qui est très
devenu référent j'ai en tête à tête
encore cavaliers f2 et tout mais il faut
calculer précisément mais en gros c'est
l'idée
en gros c'est l'idée
chez plus qu'il faut faire ici
chaleur 10 tours 8 serait peut-être que
tu as encore f4 food et 4 une fois
malade j'ai d'abord fait trois mois
et après tu vois mais c'est très chiant
comme menace c'est une menace latente et
a toujours était toujours en retard pour
ces cinq en fait je déteste ce truc et
je sais que c'est théorique et je sais
que me suis pris soin h3
et ça me fait super chez cette position
en plus je m'étais préparé dans un
moment et je me suis pris un mec qui m'a
joué genre 22 août de 22 coups de
première ligne m'a dégoûté
je rappelle plus trop comment ça se
passe mais tu peux aussi avoir un plomb
un peu con mais qui a validé un qui a
valu aux trois
là sur un truc comme dams est tu peux
même avoir ce genre de trucs qui peuvent
exister
oui là tu as peut-être fou g5 qui est
chiant
h 6 ou 3 et affaiblissent un peu en
prévision et f400 qui peut arriver
encore j'ai
perdu ma ce parti
vous faut trois directs d'ailleurs
j'aime pas les noirs en fait
je déteste jouer ce truc
était obligé un peu ouais en fait
ouais mais
[Musique]
derrière il ya aussi une variante
on
n'a pas trop le choix et ding
qui lisent ils envoient d'envoi quoi
drobo sync auvray baron
je passe c'est à 6,1 mais pourquoi pas
un
6e
mais en fait c'est le seul coup un peu
ambitieux j'ai à dire des cinq
pas votre fonds ainsi ce qui t'arrive
dessus
franchement je
sais pas ce qu'on finira peut-être
cassis c'est pas mal enfin c'est du coup
compte twitter après ouais les pour les
contre l'imposition c'est quoi c'est que
tu as tout une caste et 6 pour les
blancs un jour un cabri quirin bondir
dessus ou quoi tu as là bas le pion
isolé ou quoi après dès qu'il touche au
plan b est moins stable aussi les c3 est
toujours celle qui sur les tours c'est
lui qui a eu 4 ou comment perdre et
actif donc il ya du pour et du contre au
cias
ont dîné bonne à gaza drake indulgence a
duré huit minutes
après seeding ne gagne pas aujourd'hui
le tournoi est terminé mais toute façon
- c'est simple
complexes
précise bill hay adams trembler 6 en
fait pas le laisser là il peut le
prendre un prêt sans en discuter mais ce
n'est pas assez pas assez d'activités
pouvoir avoir cavaliers à quatre équipes
adam des huit en fête ou dames c'est sa
terre pour prendre six mais en fait ça
ça pourrait se regarder à la rigueur
pour faire une fois
pour gagner non
et s'il arrête le temps et non
aujourd'hui à jouer mais 26 ça pourrait
des petits nul partout tout le temps ou
pas ils ressortent deuxième place qui il
a fait signer mais peut-être tu peux
ignorer reprendre en b 5 oui c'est aussi
à se passer belfond à season bien non il
n'a rien
d'une grèce a peut-être bricoler tourner
autour pendant longtemps ça c'est une
autre histoire je pense qu objectivement
c'est rien oui et non ça peut tuer le
tournoi parce que du coup ci fait nul ah
ouais ça reste à un point et demi devant
c'est ça bah oui à deux rondes de la fin
non mais le truc c'est
l'afrique sinding phase 6 sur 6 pour
juste revenir ex-aequo
c'est quasi jamais vu quoi ils sont
payés sur chaque victoire et nul ils ont
intérêt à continuer à 20 jeunes n'ont
rien fait pour 3500 euros c'est comme
pour toi 50 euros en fait tout 20 euros
je ne sais même pas en fait c'est vrai
imaginer qu'ils gagnent énormément
d'argent
3500 euros c'est pas quelque chose qui
les motive en fait d'après prix fort les
ordres et les avoir mais oui et
va pas être ou là je fais pas partie de
l'année j'ai donné toutes mes prépa pour
nom laisse justement ça va se jouer
comme d'autres tournois quand il cache
quoi quand tu joues plus pour rien tu
vas pas regarder ton truc fort pour une
fois suivante mais
mes parents n'ont ils vont pas se barrer
par contre tu peux être suspendu ou as
tu pars en plein tournant alors tu dois
jouer non mais c'est juste qu'il arrête
de jouer les prépas face arrête d'être
un tournoi intéressant
ça devient un tournoi très lambda qui
joue plus pour rien quoi mais après
voilà c'est comme ça ils ont un peu
comme le psg en ligue 1 et dans le monde
regarde puis enfin tu regardes pour la
course à la ligue des champions quoi
mais là enfin là comme y'a qu'une place
je regarde parce que riche
histoire en mode supporter si tu vas
voir tu aimes bien mével dans son livre
dit qu'il ya eu environ 100000 euros par
an aux penguins maintenant en tout cas
il ya une beaucoup plus c'est sûr
nettement plus
ses fins et
yuki mvl il gagne beaucoup plus que cent
mille par an en brut 1 je veux dire
ça doit être ce qu'ils gagnent sur deux
ou trois tournois ça dépend lesquels ou
quoi mais c'est vrai que là il ya
maintenant il ya des le circuit a pris
de l'ampleur avec le magnus tour med gym
joue pas cette année mais bon voilà deux
[Musique]
legranger store
c'est
déjà si tu finis à 250 ou 300 heures de
direct je regarde les prize money ils
sont ils sont beaux quoi oui puisqu'on
ne sais pas je fais pas le calcul mais
je ne compte pas les sponsorings les
machins les matchs par équipe enfin tout
ce qui peut s'ensuivre et c'est tant
mieux enfin j'veux dire c'est au
contraire avec le plus qui gagne le
mieux c'est mais je veux dire
dans ce contexte la 3500 euros de plus
pour montrer une prépa ça aucun intérêt
quand tu pourrais montrer cette prépa
pour gagner une partie de grande chaise
tour ou une qualif pour un prochain
candidat ou en fait il ya plein
d'endroits où c'est plus intéressant
après peut-être les gars en cours soit
seconde place il peut se dire bon on est
dans le doute je cas mais c'est bien
mais
jaro qui colle à 12 9 euros déjà par
exemple
nombre énorme alors
plus que 3000 euros bien sûr beaucoup
plus
l'un des fils de l'attendu à l'époque
bah oui oui mais maxime bas et puis les
gains en tournois en bienbienbien
n'augmenter c'est normal enfin mais bon
pour 3000 euros qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'ils s'en foutent quoi
niveau mais tu es mieux les prendre son
pied donne mais oui une
nouveauté importante où cos
passa pas trop de prix en fait oui oui
et c'est normal fadjr c'est exactement
pareil dans les autres sports oui pas de
vertus passe des dizaines d'heures à une
équipe pour trouver sa fin donc tu
sais un peu gâchée quoi après bon je
sais pas et pensent qu'ils estiment
n'importe quoi et penser
tu avais pas quant à des matchs une
équipe qui est milieu de tableau ligue 1
et qui le samedi soir une finale de
coupe de la ligue ou de coupe de france
on va être le match du mercredi vont
quasiment mettre l'équipe b ils vont
demander aux mecs de passes blessés
enfin ils vont tous faim oui volontiers
troqué prix vont ils vont lever le pied
à fond et puis après quand ça va être
important ils vont tout mettre non là
c'est un peu pareil c'est ok c'est fini
le tournoi est fini et c'est pas parce
que tu as une prime de victoire à cinq
mille balles enfin en ligue 1 je sais
pas combien les la prime de victoire
mais sa bonne exemple mais mais ils en
ont rien à [ __ ] et c'est tout à fait
normal en fait c'est leur métier
donc ils vont pas gaspiller des des
prostituées je peux gagner le match
comme ça
tu gagneras mais oui
oui gagnant devra les prendre un rouge
est suspendu pour la finale où quoi par
exemple la vie ouais mais c'est damballa
sellam le même le même cas de figure
au maximum à skis ce que je veux dire
c'était pas 100 milles de revenu brut
s'étaient déjà bien plus ouais ouais ben
et c'est sûr que c'est sûr qu'après les
primo this etc comme on dit c'est du
brut dans le sens de l'homme des 3500
parce que si tu utilises une prépa pour
une fois ils sont plus dense et très pas
tu l'as acheté en quelque sorte donc ça
se fasse n'importe les gens qui
passaient pas une histoire d'argent oui
c'est ça faire quand bien même
facile ça peut l'être parce que par
exemple imagine
grande chaise tour tu vois ou soi-disant
n'y a pas d'enjeu je sais plus combien
ces maxi nous dira chez plus cet indice
est pas 250000 celui qui gagne le
circuit du ranch histoire a fâché par
house et 150 me mais voilà séparer la
cité thermale
ok tu peux même envoyé une prépa
candidats il est tellement c'est une
telle manne financière ça te fait être
100 millions de différence est que pour
investir et machin donc là tu vas le
faire mais c'est un peu chefs
d'entreprise comme en quelque sorte
donc ça évidemment l'acier en demie pour
candidats s'étaient 50000 euros
peut-être tu vois même s'il a plus
d'enjeu bon tu dis pour cette valeur là
je vais pouvoir payer 3 mai caboter à
plein temps et puis je verrai en gras
j'ai engrangé plus de nouveautés encore
et après évidemment c'est tout à fait
normal qu'ils gagnent ces sommes là pour
jouer s'il n'y a pas même pas de
discussion là dessus
c'est bien que l'élite viennent bien sa
vie quoi
alors j'ai envie de dire heureusement sa
poche ou à quelqu'un
ça ruisselle ans plaît ça dépend dans
quel sport d'ailleurs enfin ni
l'histoire où il galère encore les gars
d'autres ça va mieux ça dépend à quel
point ces médiatique
beaucoup d'appelés pour peu d'élus
sport de haut niveau
ce que vous dites c'est qu'il ya encore
un petit intérêt à jouer mais pas à
faire une partie de qualif décante pas
du coup les spectateurs sont perdants à
les spectateurs ils sont perdants de
même avant le début du tournoi a déjà
deux par le format de partout en fait
les spectateurs sont perdants sur sur
toute la ligne en fait et je pense pas
que ça c'est un détail par rapport à
tout ce qui est fait pour que les
spectateurs ne viennent pas là on est
sûr sûr vu mineurs et on va dire fallout
est perdant maintenant par point de vue
c'est que les parties étaient pas mal
sont vraiment battus les joueurs au
koala en fait le jour il ya moins
d'enjeu ça va lever le pied et avant
on
peut parler du format tant qu'on veut
quoi mais le contenu les parties étaient
pas mal
ils sont les journées à trois victoires
ou sa lutte et à fond donnez tout
jusqu'au bout s'il ya des finales de
faire durer
donc dans le jeu d'échecs pur voilà là
peut-être que maintenant si les dés sont
jetés même ça on leur a pas demandé
infâme un bon gm français combien ils
gagnent pas des bons gm français on n'a
pas beaucoup en fait mais moi en fait
fin j'ai une carrière différente celle
là je joue quasiment plus mauvaise donne
des cours donc c'est un autre manière
dîner de l'argent
est juste en jouant
dont je n'étais pas assez fort pour ça
c'est saâdane sait qu est ce qu est ce
qu on appelle bon gm en fait dont gm
nous entre nous on appelle ça un joueur
à 2007
j'imagine ouest pourrait être un poil
moins tu vois je sais pas en fait
maintenant on fait leur fait ce qu'on
veut comme dans l'échelle mais
2500 2550
battue a pas eu que du jeu enfin moins
de te pas évident quoi ah oui mais c'est
normal aussi oui non mais bon moi je
pense au programmé jeudi prochain mais
dix ans après bah si jeanne des cours
que tu fais des livres que tu fais des
vidéos que je fais des dvd tomber des
stats à un moment du diversifie tirs
venus tu peux te débrouiller faut avoir
un peu un côté se bouger quoi mais juste
en jouant
après bon le truc où on peut pas se
plaindre aux échecs c'est que
on a invité tard que même en gagner un
peu tu veux avoir une vie où tu dépenses
peu mais je pense qu'un joueur de ton
calibre vit mieux aux échecs pour les
tourner d'un côté nice à bord mais c'est
100% sur adour moi je pourrais jouer
je pas de trois semaines par mois me
balader faire des voyages un peu partout
et je pourrais en fait alors que gilles
fauré pas forcément mettre de côté il y
aura des tournois je gagnerai 0 la ville
mais tu pourrais ouais mais comme ça me
coûterait quasiment rien
je pourrais faire ça alors qu'au tennis
tu pourrais absolument pas la stupidité
tu pourrais pas et coach en matériel ton
machin c'est chaud quand
on a une économie aux échecs un peu
particulière et
bizarre
donc aucun sport c'est possible sport
individuel en faut toujours une nouvelle
fois faire le distinguo parce qu un
sport collectif c'est beaucoup plus
facile mais les sports individuels ouais
tu peux pas généralement
d'un tissu peut être moniteur de tennis
très bas comme là tu peux être prof
d'échec quoi ça faisait la même chose et
puis après selon ton niveau tu vas être
plus ou moins reconnus plus ou moins
compétents et puis il faut que le
courant passait toujours les modes
histoire
c'est ça tu as plein de gens tennis qui
était bon qui
s'inquiètent ils étaient 8 100e mondiale
ou quoi fin mais je connais bien c'est
juste pas ça
hyper bien en fait évidemment pas
beaucoup moins d des mortels mais tu
peux pas être joueur de tennis pour ce
niveau là donc battu faut autre chose
les sparrings tu fais coach tu fais
entrer notre club est sain après tu
trouve des trucs mais il tape fort un
déjà où tu switcher tu fais autre chose
de ta vie quoi puis 100e mondiale
je peux te dire d'avoir joué pour la
déjouer c'est mais le niveau même pas si
loin des tops mais
il est quand même très bon parce qu'en
fait quand ya pas deux nuls au tennis
ils ont tout le temps se faire dégommer
quoi 8 100e mondiale passée briotet
sauter je crois que c'est à partir de
150 sans que tu peux commencer à en
vivre un peu comme aux échecs quasiment
et du coup tu as des mecs un peu moins
fort qu'avant son rêve donc il tente le
coup mais comptez 3 4 5 100e mondiale
t'es tu donnes tout sur deux trois
saisons
il soit y arrive c'est tf1 qui arrive
pub et en plus tu as moins de longévité
au tennis servez arrive pas
mais ok c'est juste le sport de haut
niveau enfin y'a pas on vouloir ou pas
être content c'est comme ça
mais le truc c'est que moi je les
intègre et trop tard ça
je n'aurais pas été de 1700 en fait mais
j'aurais pu essayer de travailler plus
un moment plus jeune quoi
et me dire que m grand maître qui est
bien mais juste rien enfin s'est pas
fait et quand même pas trop bon quoi et
cherchez plus j'imagine que ça aurait
été plus fort que ce que j'ai fait pas
suffisant pour être super forme et ça
aurait été mieux mais en fait me suis un
peu laissé
ici furent mes acquis dans le sens où
justement j'étais invité renée tournoi
de ça c'était cool et j'ai pas cherché à
être ambitieux
voilà ceux qui sont plus jeunes et qui
rêve de ça c'est le conseil que je
donnerais ses visées très très fort vous
faites autre chose fait des études et
c'est pas grave
j'aurais être un bon joueur amateur et
qu on m en 2004 ou plus ou moins
comme ça
non mais c'est pas un conseil que j'ai
entendu ça en fait personne malade au
nez quand je pars quand alors à temps
alors qu'en russie c'est le conseil
qu'on donne directement soit tu peux
faire 2007 soit une audition intéresse
observé à quelqu'un - massacre - 26 50
ou amants ou alors faut avoir envie
d'être coach ça c'est différent mais au
moins 26 50 watts en dessous et même 26
50 jeunes en fait après bon selon le
pays sacs en réussite aura plus de
concurrence en france de 26 50 et pas
mal a priori titre dans l'équipe
nationale tu vas jeunes nationale
pendant deux bonnes années t'auras ton
top 12 tu auras des trucs tu vois là
tchèque adam sortir pas trop mal quoi je
veux dire
pour aller jouer dans d'autres ligues
autour c'est la france tu vas pouvoir
faire un peu de championnat d'espagne de
bundesliga
2006 on va dire en france et en russie
25 entre en 2006 mais 25 50 c'est déjà
vraiment charmé même 26 ans est un peu
nigel mais écologie la presse ici on
sent la fibre d'être coach c'est autre
chose ah c'est autre chose mais c'est
juste que tu seras pas joueur c'est ça
max a regardé j'ai eu dix ans vivent là
bas je pense
mais après tu as envie pas non plus
pas devenir millionnaire 8 aura du mal à
avoir une vie de famille et tout un
jardin voilà un moment ça m'a battue
évidemment tu calmes
tu vas pas faire genre pro jusqu'à 60
ans donc mes joueurs proust doit assumer
une famille à mon avis
comme tu disais quand tu vis seul machin
voyage que tu joues beaucoup de
tournants ou quoi mais si tu dois
assumer encore un gros loyer un machin
et tout ça peut vite être compliqué
aussi un même à 2006 en français
oui bof rompre je sais pas c'est bon
aussi la situation la famille enfin des
problèmes qu'il a semé tout seul oui mes
chers du coup c'est là que tu as besoin
de complément que ce soit
comme et aura du mal en fait c'est pas
si facile que tu va voyager
importe on se
salit sportif en fait alors que j'irai
qu'à partir de 26 50 27 et déjà quand
même plus tranquille 25 occuper un peu
ric-rac quand même
26 50 27 et tranquille et ville brasser
beaucoup à l'époque où jouent et non pas
grand-chose
basse augmenté par rapport à l'époque
les rémunérations
bref là des fois il a fait des belles
épopées il était champion d'europe il a
fait des quartiers nous devions des
trucs comme ça donc là ça devait être
des tournants qui n'ont plus la coupe du
monde que la norme d'ailleurs mais vers
des bonnes périodes et d'autres un peu
plus
parce que comme t'as jamais de revenus
réguliers battait dépendantes ta forme
de thé tournoi de six passes en ce
moment
pareil si tu avais une équipe et puis
que le sponsor et pull allen après baba
tape une équipe aussi dépendant de trucs
autour de toi
[Musique]
supporter g20 jeudi pas trop ce qu'ils
disent et c'est vrai que ça dit et
camille non mais tu dis des trucs
hallucinants fait remporté
donc à j 3
je prends la série sur le dragon
accéléré enfin le parti phalangiste
cette ouverture baladait fillon l'a
finie en fait l'astérien le répertoire
il est complet et un après ce qu'il a il
ya d'autres trucs si les blancs voient
pas d'assistanat mais c'est une autre
histoire
si on fait déjà la pine d'etienne fermé
des f4 défouler 5d mais sur la sienne
ouverte pai a un répertoire entier quoi
[Musique]
complètement
du coup on vous fait un autre répertoire
plus facile oui mais
plus solide solidaire
donc
aussi quoi déjà ta voix de fermer ses
fins de paolo cian verdejo soli mode est
ce qu'on veut et après sur leur herbe
ont accéléré bon en général peut-être si
elle mieux c'est le maroc 6 ou la vente
avec
et qui foutent rohff psy4
on est deux qui peuvent peut-être donner
le plus d'espoirs côté blanc d'obtenir
quelque chose
ça m'a traversé les îles de devenir
coach que je donnais des cours pendant
peut-être 6 7 ans je pense quelque chose
comme ça au début de la chaîne et puis
après j'ai plus le temps mais j'aimais
bien en fait c'était cool
comment il ya autant d'argent avec du
message dans le sens que c'est énorme
mais aussi beaucoup d'argent public 1 en
vrai
globalement donc je suis les échecs
c'est à peu près mécénat slash argent
public moi je sais pas trop qu'on marche
l'écosystème en jeu
en gros c'est un peu les deux oui
beaucoup comme la commune i dat de
madrid oui c'est pas pour l'espagne mais
pour la france a quand même beaucoup de
clubs as tu parlé du top 20 pour le duff
16 des mairies il donne des budgets par
des sponsors à côté ça dépend mais oui
oui souvent les mairies te donne enfin
qu'ils ont envie de développer les
échecs comme activité mais c'est souvent
cet argent public et mécénat
elle a fait h3 ouais ça fait la position
ça va quand même a les fesses tu as
raison je vois pas un gros avantage
blanc mais ne va pas perdre non plus un
hors-jeu 3 baup il veut pas avoir de
pièce débarquer angers 4 c'est éviter
des défauts deux genres rock je pense
pas que ça marche mais ça pourrait
paroisse g1 déjà c'est d'un match
cadenassé problème alors quand ce sera
fini de retraite atteindrait 5 ta tête
avec 4 mais bon en gros ça évite toutes
ces idées là à long terme et h3c
empêcher kg 400 belges beaucoup de
choses fausses et c'est donc l'être
bonnes questions pour ton pions
je pense qu'il va partir il peut
peut-être prendre un nom qui a plus fous
mais mon tour à tour elle sera contente
vous subite poussée 8 ouais tu reviens
quand même là
tu fais à 4 maintenant mais bon tu
lâches la case b4 il n'y a pas eu
d'ailleurs trop ravi de le faire le coup
d'avant
je sais pas non mais je n'aime pas
tellement sa position
est que de tourner ainsi pas traîné
pour se venger sur des 5 et
déjà on peut prendre du
web annonce est débile
laisse regarder ça mais que l'on prend à
tour h5 non mais c'est un truc bien ça
car jusque là en fait ça a commencé à
être mieux au nom on va donc le
même super des 5 g pas comment un jour
dans un pur basse et la batterie perdre
deux arrêts mais tu arrives en hausse à
l'ouverture
toujours jouer à haut niveau ça peut
arriver de temps en temps
ça peut arriver je crois que ça jamais
été jouée au niveau
mais pas top top lagarde oui mais les
meilleurs d'armes surprise ouais ouais
c'est ça mais
pas trop après la viennoise qui est un
peu plus je sais qu'elle et ses 3 g iii
mon plus grand rapport trouble ou non il
a fait les quatre cavaliers mais dans
l'esprit mais même ça c'est pas c'est
prometteur
l'envirronement quasi jamais
fait quelques décennies que c'était fini
quoi
bah je vais bien mais le concerne moreau
une fois j'avais dans un ou une chaise
je sais pas je commence à schirrhein de
4,5 m3 et il dit ayew stop la kfor dont
j'avais envie de jouer grand miroir
petit simply blenders open after it ex
efforts
hier qu'on veut je n'avais pas eu cette
grande aventure de base dont qui le dit
un peu de manière humoristique mais en
fait ils trouvent que oui a accepté le
miroir c'est bien pour les noirs
juste un petit tour il se passe pas
grand chose sur les autres parties live
ou étroit qu'on attendait et se
réfléchit
mais moi ya peut-être des 4 après je
sais que c'est théorique donc forcément
c'est que ça peut aller ce genre de
choses moi j'arrive jamais à le jouer en
fait
puisque j'y arrive pas que c'est pas
possible
web et 4 c'est quoi ces x 6 baisser
un petit tour des intermédiaires
je t'aime gérant bien vite mais je sais
pas un recul
publicis qui savent important
ça donne à peu près acquis mais bon j'ai
pas vraiment pas visuellement près
le reflux des jeunes talents pour les
échecs car ça j'en ai aucune idée mais
ce que ce que je sais c'est que les
échecs en chine c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement mineurs c'est pourtant se
développer parce que c'était un temps on
est malgré tout genre avant c'était le
néant ivi john cho année mais après tout
a tellement d'autres jeux qui sont plus
mal pour eux c'est comme pour l'un du
show guy tu vois
legault alors s'en fout un peu alors que
c'est les échecs mais même le jeu où ils
s'en foutent ils sont quand même bien
après ils ont toujours été plutôt pas
mal avec les joueuses ouais
le championnat du monde
mais chez les joueurs c'était mineur
après dans une belle génération mais
ils durent pas jarry fade
jazzy plus
oui mais les professeurs du niveau là
dans wolf et sa life mais je dirais trop
d'échecs quoi c'est le cas mais mais en
fait j'ai l'impression que je joue aux
échecs c'est pas un aboutissement
spéciale pour brison d'inga revient sur
la mairie l'ont hué wailly
ya
mais oui aussi il a fait des études et
il fait une vie normale en fête se tient
là le je crois que pour en fait joueur
d'échecs professionnel c'est et qu'on
sert pas trop souvient denis auguin
il a arrêté il est plus les nerfs faut
une épreuve physique chez plus
mon bijou et
yun junghee way ont eu et il a arrêté
oui bon on ne va plus alors qu'ils
étaient forts
yong il cherchait alors lui joue
toujours mail un peu rétrograde et
je sais pas trop par exemple dans
d'autres mais qui sont moins forts
il est même dit green les diplômés de
droit à l'université de pékin mais a
[Musique]
déjà demandé un pote chinois
il m'avait dit en fait ouais que c'était
ouais c'est un jeu qui enfin
pourquoi tu fais ça en fait ces genres
socialement c'est pas trop ça c'est pas
très bon a reconnu tony ouais mais après
je sais pas tu vois c'est j'ai demandé
ça un pote je sais pas à quel point
c'est vrai enfin tu vois c'est mais bon
vu que je lis pas le mandarin et que
c'est difficile d'accepter d'avoir accès
aux informations en chine
et que lui par le mandarin
forcément mais bon ça reste la vie d'un
pote j'ai un peu de chine enfin tu rêves
il paraît que il paraît que ouais
vrai que les échecs comme quoi c'était
vraiment un truc giga mineurs mais oui
j'imagine c'est comme si en france du
oui je suis champion de shogi
frère de l'affinité d'études
je pense pas que ce soit
après le truc c'est que c'est vrai qu'on
puisse sont pas trop exporté allait
déménager ailleurs chez toi c'est vrai
tu ne pas être reconnus battu d'ubs ag
ur aux états unis gélifiée pas où josé
chaque fois ne sont pas envie oui non il
faut que j'arrive ne le font pas à ces
champions 2 go personnes weezy façade
champion de france de go je sais pas
infliger peur de manquer de respect un
gars qui est vraiment champion de france
2 go et peut-être qu'il est même dans le
chat tu vois on n'en sait rien mais je
me dis doit pas pouvoir vivre du go je
me trompe peut-être
un jeu ici veut faire seuls ceux qui
partent du grenelle i way et je sais pas
mais bon ça je voulais dire dans la
contresens avec deux échecs pour chinois
mais pourtant c'est un super beau jeu
legault il ya moins de dix pros du bourg
en france ouais c'est ça
j'ai un jean pote qui est bon à league
of legends lie les parties est parti en
corée
s'il est dans le tchat
il peut être dans le chatt 1
c'est un peu rugueux réagir le chat de
manière plus intelligente que d'habitude
est ce que tes proches ont soutenu au
début dans son pré le stream bah en fait
moi je streamé et je travaillais à côté
donc
je ne gênait personne quoi
mais j'ai toujours fait un peu ma life
de mon côté en fait
je suis parti très tôt de chez moi aussi
à vivre à l'étranger du coup
début du tour de france dans dix minutes
fab sur les routes du tour du coup on se
lance à
la bascule ouais
on est gamin on les place devant un
échiquier calage 3 4 ans tu veux quand
tu veux en fait on
a pris un joli jeu ses échecs et à ping
pong
des gommes quoi tu te fais pas chier à
les déplacer
comme ça non détrompe-toi tient pour des
billes de sujets
voilà trois ans que j'avais appris
et je vois des parents la possible puis
ça dépend aussi ce que voulant fin et
puis l'enfant convient d'agir
je pense
réseau il réagit bien en fait vous
l'apprenez jeune il aime bien y rejouer
pourquoi pas apprécié il dit c'est quoi
ce
très mal aux protocoles quoi bon alors
tourbillon il fera autre chose quoi les
pièces sont vérifiées très moche
d'ailleurs
il te défonce les pièges voir ce jeu
débile
trois ans et entre en maternelle c'est
encore un peu bd genre gérer toutes les
règles de chaque pièce bas j'ai fait une
vidéo 1 pour apprendre les échecs aux
enfants si quelqu'un peut mettre le lien
où j'explique comment faire même si son
petit où tu peux jouer qu'avec les pions
petit à petit c'est tout expliqué mais
bon vidéo très très sous-estimé
le redis nous demande si on pense que
les points d'accueil sont à ce point fan
de vélo
pour bien rentrer bétail probablement
que c'est ça je pense soit chez 3 pi
choix que j'ai que vous étiez bois
colmar
champion de france 2 go est un corps et
un expatrié je crois et d'un
documentaire arte intéressant sur
comment il a aidé à entraîner l'ia qui a
battu meilleur joueur du monde assez
intéressant et gens qui mettent
le lien vers la dite vidéo
j'ai kiffé ta vidéo pour les enfants ça
a permis d'apprendre à jouer à ma copine
pourquoi pas
mais quatre cinq ans tu peux apprendre
trois ans tu peux déjà tu peux apprendre
important mais après je verrai dire il
faut que ça plaise
sa place contre les force à jouer
il ya beaucoup de gens en france qui vit
des échecs sans être des bons joueurs à
je pense que oui un vrai temps plein
dans les jambes avec leurs animateurs
aussi mal pas mal de partenariat école
n'y a pas besoin d'être il ya beaucoup
de gens qui veulent des échecs en france
je sais pas combien mais
j'ai pas la stat mazet pas récent
mais non je suis en suisse ça représente
plus d'un millier de personnes
personnellement tu as beaucoup de gens
qui donnent des cours dans les écoles
ça ne demande pas d'être très forts
d'apprendre à quoi on sert partir de 15
16 cents tu peux un bon viendra - qui
font même à moins après être entraîneur
d'échec c'est différent quatre
animateurs quand même deux choses
différentes entre h accès plus de 2100
je sais pas enfin je vais pouvoir mais
je veux dire c'est comme au tennis ou un
niveau minimum d'un mois par an j'aurais
pas dû être comptés ni après je peux y
arriver le gain peut les règles mais
voilà mes cheveux pas
photos certifiées quoi
c'est normal demandé un niveau minimum
pour expliquer des trucs parce qu'il
faut avoir bien compris savoir le
réaliser soi-même pour pouvoir le
montrer ses 2100 minimum pour être
entraîneur et
le titre à avoir été classé 15/2 bat
maso du coup ils pourraient way
vas-y moi je vais les coûts 15 2 puis je
faire prof de tennis beau métier tu
penses tu pourrais ou pas 15,2 et je
m'en bats contre je dirais que oui mais
en fait ça se trouve c'est super dur et
je crois pas mais je me dis oui enfin
le diplôme d'entraîneur a récemment été
ouvert à partir de 1800 lots à bas après
on peut tous descendre comme à l'époque
de ses fils était 2002 j'ai balancé 1000
mais bientôt ce sera 15 cents
mais je pense que
faut pas tirer les trucs vers le bas
c'est une valeur c'est tout
je voudrais
attention parce qu'en fait la position
falorni mais encore 0 heure avec un
couvent en fait la position d'alireza
elle peut tourner ces maghrébins pour
jouer avec les noirs je sais que moi je
me fais toujours défoncé bon ça veut pas
dire qu'elle est réservé à perdre parce
qu'il est mille fois plus fort et qu'on
puisse il a le temps mais je sais que ce
truc là genre tu peux en deux temps
trois mouvements est foutue injuste en
fait les pions avant c'est fini
evo genre réponse tactique richard
affaires b 4 c 5 pour taper sur e4 où la
tuerie il essaye de jouer avec b 4 x 6
et daf fin en fait de toucher le cadre
de toucher sa diagonale et d'empêcher en
fait mais c'est que tactique web et 4 ça
a l'air d'être mais si tu y arrives pas
en fait juste tu as ça qui va t'arriver
sur la gueule un cavalier ou quatre
fonds ans et cinq fins et wayne rooney
déjà en fait après fc1 caf si c'est fin
c'est tout de suite finie c'est du coup
par coup mais tu te rates un coup c'est
à bonbons
après ces longues c'est peut-être plus
simple quand blitz en bits c'est
vraiment horrible
mais qu en blitz sur est capable de
regarder mon la ja qui a éprouvé 5 mais
même si c'était un truc avec la tour en
huit ans c'est rien mais en admettant
qu'ils puissent pas prendre il faudrait
déjà regardé pour jouer des trucs de ce
type là genre ça que tu vois
moi tu regardes mais bon même là ça
passe pas mais ça fait pour donner un
exemple tu peux de voir filer un pion
pour jouer sur le budget bachand est
active et après tu tapes sur qu'as-tu
machine et
mais tu peux pas prendre ça à la légère
en fait
ce que les blancs ils ont une idée
stratégique qui te tue quoi je d'état
jouer ce truc
genre une marche non le désert non ça
c'est non non mais t'as pas le droit de
parler à quelqu'un quand tu te déplaces
normalement non après c'est plus ou
moins toléré à leur candidat alors tu
sais que non c'est toléré en europe 1 va
faire ça dans un tournoi en russie
tu vas te faire défoncer non mais
réellement et j'avais un une amie russe
qui avait joué en france et qui est
retourné en russie qui est revenu en
russie regardez j'ai garé mauvaises
habitudes l'arbitré venu me défoncer à
duke et ses premiers dernier
avertissement tu parle encore à
quelqu'un tu dégages bien fait en france
j bonjour comment ça va enfin non merci
non mais c'est plus logique
ap ap ap un mais bon on nous rabat en
france j'ai toujours vu ça depuis que
louis c'est un truc très graves en
france est tolérée mais c'est interdit
dans les règles
mais il met du coup les usages fait
l'europe en france mais en espagne on
n'est ni enfin partout j'ai joué en fait
mais chez les vrais tu peux pas
mais les russes ont raison d'ailleurs
non mais en fait je suis d'accord pour
qu'il parle pas tu peux pas demander des
aides pas avoir de triche du coup pas
cher c'est juste que tu viens pour jouer
aux échecs tu joue aux échecs et tu vas
parler après enfin c'est pas logique
mais non
parce que je jouerai aussi bonne aura
point we can quoi mais c'est pas
vraiment
non si tu vas mais je sais pas comment
ça se passe genre en inde ou quoi est-ce
qu'ils sont aussi strictes que j'ai
jamais joué en inde je joue aux états
unis mais en fait comme j'étais parti
tout seul je connaissais personne
j'étais quand même bonjour aux gens je
connaissais mais gérard parlait pas
j'ai joué en australie ben
je ne trouvais pas très strictes après
je parle est passé à 3 fermées de façon
à nos peines jean-noël zélande
bon bah je prends pas quitte empêché de
faire
ouais non mais c'est vrai dans les pays
de l'est sur la question globale genre
en islande sa part jean letard sa part
enfin ça parle partout comme outreau
mais c'est interdit en plus on rit cdu
csu et l arrêt comme le monde fait tu
fais
pas jambes
pas avec mega bavarde on est parti je
suis assez concentré des fois tu crois
que je viens et a pas eu depuis
longtemps tu as ça va changer
ok france va prêtre je vais pas fan non
discussions en voiture
bah oui ils sont plus strictes avec ça
la prison peut-être beaucoup plus de
marloux aussi peut-être parce que l'aéro
flotte il ya des fois de ses cinémas
dans les chiottes
c'est incroyable
et du coup c'est pire enfin
dira si tu parle juste pour dire bonjour
et que l'on envoie chier alors que les
autres ont des signes ah ben je parle
pas et déjà eu droit
rich iott ça peut être très particulier
non mais ils essayent de lutter au
maximum légère c'est peut-être qu'ils
ont plus à faire à des marges ou même
jour sans fin
mai après genre surtout les championnats
les championnats nationaux ou quoi là
c'est vraiment ultra stricte c'est pas
pour une question de marloux c'est juste
que tu vas super finale du championnat
de russie machin c'est pourtant des
mouches voler ouais c'est strict stricte
géniaux la range ou shatner dans les
chiottes
il y avait eu un gars qui avait planqué
un téléphone dans l'échappée on est tous
arrivé dans plein de tourner enfin plein
bas fait maintenant il ya ces districts
contrôlés bien mais qui est riche et un
d'open aux émirats ou au qatar où je
sais pas où comme ça passe
avec pas ou
2004 je sais pas quoi et mais il est
français juste tout le monde mais un
moment juste comprend que c'est pas
normal quoi donc en fait sont pas très
bien quand ils font ce à quoi ils sont
forcément choper
lankais les téléphones c'est typique
ouais
y'a des fois ça prend des années mais
des fois il soulève des trucs
pour les fous
non mais gérer finement autres comme ça
non mais je m'en voudrais enfin je
l'aurais montre enfin c'est juste
je sais enfin moi je les suspendre à vie
et dégage à tout jamais les gens qui
font ça c'est fini enfin c'est on n'est
pas assez méchant avec les gens qu'on
triche on
est bon qu'on ne fait pas les règles par
contre moi le truc c'est qu'ils ont
purgé leur peine maintenant ils doivent
être réintégrés et puis c'est que le
cigare il était aussi strict qui
n'auraient peut-être pas tricher donc tu
peux pas a posteriori changer la règle
c'est fini pour une fin en fait pour moi
tricher aux échecs c'est trop grave quoi
parce que c'est même pire que le dopage
dans le sport parce que tu t'es sûr
gagner en fait j'ai toujours l'exemple
que je pense et si moi
je vais faire et on va prendre le vélo
parce que c'est trop de stéréotypes mais
je joue au tennis avec tous les projets
que tu veux je cours partout mais je
vais pas prendre un point et un miracle
mais j'ai pas prendre un jeu quoi
contre un mec du big four mais par
contre un joueur de tennis qui ses pages
aux échecs juste y comprends tu
l'envoies les coûts ce qu'a fait quoi à
lui me défonce donc en fait c'est pas
equideow espalem trichant 21 une chose
est sûre de gagner l'autre juste eu
cours plus donc pour eux safa 90
différence mais tu as besoin de
prérequis techniques ou quoi donc en
fait très chaud échec c'est
pourquoi l'ancien qui planquent des
préparent leurs sous-vêtements ou leurs
chaussures alors je sais qu'il ya des
joueurs de haut niveau qui ont été très
fortement soupçonnée d'aider des prépa
des prépa plaquait lankais et des
joueurs qui ont été très très très très
fortement soupçonné
après rien de prouvé
mais ça c'est un truc
c'est sûr c'est déjà arrivé et
je veux dire avoir un téléphone va
regarder les coups ça c'est encore une
notice de triche mais ça c'est encore
pire on va dire mais
pour moi c'est non et puis mes pieds
dans un tournoi de ta vie vaut pour ta
gueule quoi
et oui ça ça c'est
rick trouve peut-être certains joueurs
de haut niveau qui se trompait jamais
dans leur prépa des prépa incroyable et
qui trouvaient toujours dans votre
mémoire traite une très bonne voie et
qu'elle est systématiquement aux
toilettes dans l'ouverture et ça
arrivait à très très haut niveau et à
et après ça jamais été prouvée il aurait
fallu passer par par des fouilles
poussées mais bon
mais c'est assez c'est assez terrible
des fouilles anales bas c'est exactement
ce que ce que va préconiser un
avant toutes les parties et en bas de
haut niveau il disait il faut vraiment
être sur quoi
c'était la préconisation de denos ram la
douce
la mer est pourquoi je suis aussi
violent dans leurs devoirs pour les
tricheurs c'est que le prix à payer est
passé faire par rapport au peu de cas
que tu trouves jarreau this qui a pu
faire des années enfin
versée depuis longtemps on sait quoi et
justes tant que tu le trouves pas il
fait donc ça aurait pu durer pendant 20
ans quoi enfin je sais pas un moment où
ça s'arrête mais peut-être elles ont peu
de risques est-ce que tu risques par
rapport à nombre de parties que tu as
gagné machin que c'est chiant donc en
fait le giron de chopes tout soit
terminé finito quoi on ne voit plus un
sur l'échiquier voilà un point final
donc là au moins tu restes un vrai truc
tu fais ta et puis après tout finito
sing it all
one drop aux ordis bata loire mais le
truc c'est qu'il n'y a plus de jour
devant justement à cause de ce à quoi
particulier l'émergence des ordis il ya
plus deux jours de manga on dit dans
quelques temps il y aura des joueurs
puces et waimes ça va être le nouveau
problème un très clairement ah ben voilà
bon enfin on y voit plus rien ou y avait
le problème j'y pensais ya longtemps
mais ça n'a pas marché ce truc c'est
dégueulasse
ouais mais c'était ce à deux reprises
mais je pensais que j'avais développé
que
mes trucs de la puce dans l'intestin
c'est vraiment dur à détecter hélas
après horrible mais ça arrivera un jour
où l'autre là c'est pas encore la fin
c'est pas encore le cambrai on n'en sait
rien les petits sic
avant chaque partie kevin
il a trouvé à lire et bon certaine qu'on
a regardé
ça m'inquiète un peu mais en fait c'est
sur c'est théorique et donc du coup tu
peux faire
tu peux tenir coi
puisses interne qui te fait du morse
pour te donner découvrir ça c'est après
quand on en arrivera là et on en est pas
loin je sais pas quelles solutions ils
trouveront un
as
c'est la ligne qu'on a analysé tout à
l'heure avec fab et ça semblait égale
donc ça va aller
caruana rapporte ça va jouer ça va ça va
cliquer mais c'est pas forcément une
partie très intéressante en vue du
classement
et radjabov ding tourcoing six tours d
un hockey
une tour prend tout reprend ainsi ses
tours d un
tu veux qu'on fasse une petite pause
ouais 1h15
ouais petit plus petite pause
on peut en profiter un peu fabing on les
a pas pris jusqu'à maintenant donc on
peut profiter puis à déjà plus grand
monde qui suit en plus fab donc on peut
bien profiter là
vas-y pub
et pose à tout
les amis on espère qu'il s'est pas passé
grand chose en notre absence normalement
il s'est rien passé puisque tout ce qui
devait se passer aujourd'hui c'est déjà
passé à fab au final les deux nuls donc
là maintenant on fait un peu de
l'intendance je sais pas trop comment
appeler sa fab
regardez un peu la partie de farruggia
au final
si vous voulez on sait pas trop quoi
faire en fait d'en discuter pendant la
pause on se disait ben
il va apprendre la kalach
duda en fait on n'a pas trop le choix
ouais
intéressante du ku'damm
7,1 les gens sortent deux coups
est ce que si on faisait tous rade et
indirects de tous ces quatre ça change
un truc où ces dames 7e 6e
ok
ok bon bah nous allons prendre la cloche
qui faisait 5 évidence il n'y a pas
d'âme prend
mais à cause de freins f7
c'est ça qui va bouger saddam prises et
fit j'apprends des fluides et donc
débloquer une qualité mais le pion v2
est très pénible
ça peut même être the bet dieter
d'alireza aujourd'hui un
bond après ta câble x 2 qui va de la
gare n'était c'est de faire et 4,5
toujours
pour pratiquer tous est déjà passée n'y
a plus d'enjeu sur le temps avait
apparemment ding sa position sa part un
miracle qu'il a gagné seeding ne gagne
pas aujourd'hui
bon c'est un point et demi d'avancé à
deux rondes de la fin des beaux arts et
blanc allait leur faire nul enfin
aller très loin tout ça
surtout que
donc ouais en vrai patron a touché à sa
fin enfin c'est juste nous on va devoir
rester devant parce qu'on est on est
plus ou moins obligé mais on veut pas
vous mentir et que vous envisagiez ce à
quoi
quel intérêt des carreaux de faire nul
aujourd'hui pourquoi pas ils allaient
noir enfin comment tu joues avec les
noirs si le mec veut faire nul en phase
avec ton répertoire c'est l'énergie
noise en fait t'as pas trop le choix
c'est comme ça puis dire en plus c'est
pas mal de temps soit puisqu'il peut
plus finir premier et que éventuellement
la seconde place pour
en cas de refus tirage scène de jouer et
efficace yves donc il reste en course
pour la deuxième place ou signer pour
attraper un co vide voilà juste avant le
score
[Musique]
puis bon il est à deux points quand même
il prendrait les risques il a déjà la
chance de gagner minimes et quand bien
même il resterait encore un point
derrière et c'est dommage on serait
quand même il a compromis quand il se
met en grande difficulté ils se donnent
des grandes chances de perdre pour
pour pas grand chose au final donc il
avait aucun intérêt à jouer
à bien faire moi je
fais deux jours vaudra cette partie là
ils vont pas
j'ai envie dire d'autant plus après la
partie d'hier
non mais je crois que
ce niveau est fait nul hier il aurait
fait ça non non bien sûr mais d'autant
plus quand même oui
gère détrompe toi
fossé semble jouer au pas le choix donc
les réseaux va bouger la dame saint
james et ça paraît logique après il a
quand même une autre option c'est ça oui
parce que dame prend on peut prendre le
fou et toi prends tu peux intercepter
mais va pas faire
ça c'est juste mieux blanc ouais
clairement d'ailleurs
que c'est facile de faire nul facilement
contre une turbine en ayant les blancs
non à tarbes ils s'en foutent fait mal
de phase iib les programmes et projets
ça dépend s'il est programmé pour gagner
oui en fait ça il est pas programmés
pour gagner potentiellement oui mais si
j'ai programmé pour gagner ses galons
rien
n'en sera pas facile du tout quand tu
vas perdre mes amis si les problèmes
pour gagner ça peut être assez
élémentaire mais si les progrès à faire
du pardon pas pour accepter le nul
d'ailleurs s'il est programmé pour
accepter nul dans le cas où il est moins
bien il suffit peut-être juste de
proposer tu veux 80
et va être pragmatique
entre les carl scène les meilleurs font
quoi ils perdent ce que je veux qu'ils
fassent
rien à perdre lors d'une
rixe cas tu proposes nul est normalement
tu prend normalement il prend
rappelons comment il est programmé en
fait ouais
alors choisi avec des quatre donc la f3
ou c'est qu'il ya trop plein de coups
mais bref trois pages de cannes de dh 4
mai à 4 je pense à ces trois cas relief
3 3 des trois tout ça ça doit passer
trois voire beaucoup plus fort que des
troncs le terroir de française
aurait des trois tu pourra suivre par g3
et ferrari this way
c'est 2,3 tu te dis chouette finlandaise
peut faire trois poisons je peux faire
b3 foulée de 20h pas
beaucoup plus sexy et plus on peut
donner
un os 7 on pouvait voir assis radja
gagne c'est vraiment terminé à dos quoi
vrai ding on en a pas parlé avant le
début de la partie mais c'est vrai que
il a joué plusieurs marathons 1 pour
remonter et peut-être qu'aujourd'hui il
bloque un peu physiquement aux siens
mais j'aime pas trop ce qui a faim dans
l'ouverture j'en ai pas trop ravi ne
changent pas d'avis sur ce qui se passe
ça pourra être magnifique d'avoir un
dépôt à deux points d'avancé à deux
rondes de la fin
fin de game
magnifique non
l'aspirant ce que je dis
et si ça s'ils prenaient en d5 tuer ça
attendez d'eux je crois un bolide
non
beaucoup de jeunes vont
peut-être tu dois faire quoi on va
tomber non plus rater mal mais c'est
tout quoi mettant des deux je ne sais
pas trop enfin la chance qu'ils
anticipent dame b mais en fait d'un v8
rock tour ses huit fait j'étais juste
pas dire quoi
plus ou moins le même truc mais t'as pas
tout
c'est la catastrophe
l'aspect d'une défaite express de ligne
peut-être
incroyable
quand tu joues mal avec les normes plus
élevées
du fait des coûts normaux et et bien
quoi
hier j'ai découvert les vidéos cette
battle sur youtube qui à leur égard leur
action sur les énorme connerie des
joueurs
il y en a beaucoup à rattraper
tabarre on fout sur un conseil tabarre
on s'oublie stream sur youtube tu vas
kiffer
j'ai reçu le tee shirt je clique au
hasard hier super matière très
confortable j'en suis très content va
n'hésite pas à me contacter sur twitter
que je puisse que je puisse te re tweeté
bien sûr point d'exclamation shop pour
acquérir le t-shirt superbe maillot tu
le vois derrière fab vite ce magnifique
les woody les woody qui partent comme
des petits pains en fait part de partout
il ya bientôt plus de doubles xl
d'ailleurs
terrible
c'est toi qui fait la voix des leçons de
chaises comme oh que oui
grande question ou et baron fou pendant
ce temps à des candidats il est il
regarde les récap de cornetto et après
il va à la partie jouée 1
dames c8 donc et pourquoi pas aussi un
tu veux faire du faux f5 peut-être du
fou
radja je pense qu'il arrive contre une
petite nul peut-être aussi peut-être
rock froid je crois
[Musique]
mais je pense que dit il a intérêt à
vite trouver un truc sert de jeu essayer
de faire annuler en force sinon la juste
perdre de manière expéditive
oh que oui
j'aime pas ce que tu veux que les bombes
c'est catastrophique
quand même maillot belette dans le shop
un
double cd
et le cdr est
il déçu de ces candidats moi non alors
sa maman je suis pas déçu ça a pas mal
joué au final et c'est assez agréable à
suivre
[Musique]
c'est toi qui as du coût ht pour ton toi
et ton frère le collier parti
aujourd'hui il devrait être là pour
mardi merci beaucoup à ben ouais on fait
du sav minutes ici
qui a le plus déçu de ces candidats
selon vous baffier route jacent
sans hésitation dans ces citations
partie sympa mais suspense un peu faible
ouais mais après je dois dire que de
toute façon
[Musique]
on a vu les matchs championnat du monde
à vue de façon tous les tournois conçu
on en suit beaucoup sur la chaîne
globalement que tous ces tournois sont
globalement assez inintéressant à suivre
donc au bout d'un moment en fait on le
sait et on part plus alors moi j'ai
moins de frustration par rapport à ça
aussi à des parties à suivre des partis
mais en fait je dis bon c'est de la
merde et enfin tant pis c'est mon métier
en fait qu'est-ce que je m'en fous mais
je plus de frustration est donc en fait
quand tu t'attends à rien tu es moins
déçu je m'attendais à rien mais je suis
quand même déçu non mais tu achètes un
peu agacé quand il y avait la hype des
échecs de me retiens c'est qu'on de
perdre l'aipac cause d'abrutis qui font
des formats de merde est en fait
maintenant du monde façon là il peut
aller perdu c'est de la merde je m'en
fout en fait c'est fait c'est fait tant
pis quoi on va attendre 20 ans bond sera
plus là on sera plus là et puis c'est en
pire c'est les générations d'après qui
en perd un prix nous
on va dire ce truc-là fait que c'est
plus cool
je crois que c'est déjà foutu pour dodig
je cherche des coups je voudrais dire
qu'elle prend des cinq n'a pas du tout à
cause de cavaliers prend des cinq dames
france et 8 tours france et 8 tu en
prends des cinq tours en d2 tout reprend
des 6 x 4 non
une tour c'est un hutu rebellin à étapes
pas encore genre f4v tombèrent dans les
tourbières
ça m'a foutu a absolument rien puisque
rock des fourrages 3
vidéo je pense qu'on l'appellera les
candidats
pitot
la fidh en train de nous copier ouais
mais disons là il peut passer
ah oui non c'est fini en fait si tu
rates sera plus là ça va reprendre au
moins trois quatre cinq ans à partir de
maintenant prenant que des bonnes
décisions pour espérer un peu revenir
mais en fait il va falloir réhabituer
les gens leur montrer que c'est pas de
la mer tu recommences à venir petit à
petit c'est maintenant c'est très long
en fait une arrive c'est très facile et
très rapide à perdre et c'est très long
à récupérer c'est un peu comme un
restaurant où enfin genre tu te fais une
bonne réputation tant restaurant et
plainte est un bon cuistot tout marche
bien et tu sers de la merde pendant deux
mois en fait très vite tu vas perdre
tous tes clients et ça va prendre
énormément de temps à les récupérer en
fait et deux mois tu fais de la merde
sont beaucoup plus cher que les trois
mois août a été excellent même puisque
trois de moins que les trois ans je
voulais dire désolé je merci fable de
m'avoir corriger
et donc là en fait le fait d'avoir fait
de la merde comme ça
j'y viens liquide pendant deux ans en
fait ça pour attraper sa faut peut-être
faire cinq ou six ans d'exceptionnel en
fait
on en doute et ça on n'en doute way déjà
dû moyens ils ont du mal donc de
l'exceptionnel ça va être dur donc en
fait on se fait une raison enfin
wells à la conf à la confiance se gagne
difficilement il se perd en deux
secondes exactement donc là ils ont
réussi vraiment a complètement tué tout
l'intérêt qu'il pouvait y avoir dans les
échecs et bravo à eux parce que ce
n'était pas simple en fait non il ya un
vrai engouement hors intérêts il ya un
vrai engouement il ya eu un vrai truc
qui s'est passé pendant le confinement
il a fallu vraiment le le tuer dans
l'oeuf et
et là ils ont ils ont ils ont été
excellents et maintenant ça va être
vraiment long pour revenir
t-shirt comment des écoutes tu nous
enverra une petite photo sur les réseaux
pour une saison 2 de fringe dont une en
mai une saison 2 c'est non mais là c'est
de 3,5 les formats qui a là les gens ils
reviendraient qu'une fois et ce sera oui
c'est toujours autant de la merde oui on
repart tout de suite en fait donc non
mais après voilà à rodez on ira poche 3
non non non mais tu vas y avait une
frustration encore l'an dernier parce
que tu sais c'est tellement dommage en
fait et puis maintenant c'est fait c'est
fait c'est comme ça c'est comme ça en
tout cas ils ont bien sont bien gavés de
fric grâce à ça et bravo à eux
ils ont fait quoi de pas bien ben tout
en fait
facile d'énumérer si l'on fait de bien
mais bon on va pas en reparler pour la
cinq cent cinquantième fois sur le live
maintenant c'est fait c'est fait et puis
c'est pas grave et puis et puis quelque
part c'est peut-être tant mieux les gens
puissent intéresser petits tas d'autres
choses
enfin peut-être mieux en mieux en fait
nous a manqué notre mise pour yves
pleinement ses candidats non mais enfin
ça change pas le problème de fond que tu
es maxime qui joue ça change pas une
hype en fait ça c'est rancourt français
et franco français et c'est ça change
pas en fait
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas le
problème
peu importe c'est fait c'est fait un
vrai tu vois dans toutes les langues ah
ouais c'est partout la source indycar ou
je sais pas qui ils sont mais quelques
milliers alors normalement
quelques dizaines de milles
à quatre ça passe
bas à quatre titres et juste des
faiblesses en plus de prendre des fous
brigade soit encore plus floue et est ce
que les t-shirts taille serrée où larry
taille normale en fait je dirais
un ring taille comme les t-shirts m que
j'achète d'habitude quand il dira normal
ils sont ni plus large ni plus serré je
ris taille normale l'état libyen il
taille bien
pour la chanson j'entends le loup le
renard et la belette et merci à toi ô
diable aux belles musiques merci
c'est à mon tour de 10000 m et c'est
assez peu en fait en réalité aussi
et beaucoup et peu à la fois sage a pris
le tournant de temps a été serré la
celui-là on était entre 6 et 7000 quand
le tournoi un là on est bon à baisser
vraiment beaucoup sur la femme est là
parce que le vainqueur est déjà décidé
mais l'an dernier c'était plus dans les
dix mille ouais
mais tu vas championnat du monde deux
litres ont été déjà -
et là encore - et
pas orphelins green je sais pas ah bon
on espère les dingueries les dingues non
là il a fait g3 et g5
c'est un fou furieux mais je pense va
refaire sa partie tant pis on express et
on va remontrer
beaucoup de colonnes et les blancs ont
des tours
ça c'est les candidats frérot de bon
après c'est pas foutu non mais j'ai
versé
en fait il peut être il part du principe
que jusqu'à très peu un coup
oui mais voilà ça a du sens mais même
s'il qualifie
4c qui avec 4
qui vont voir des colonnes vers le roi
et tu vas perdre ton à tous les deux
[Musique]
après c'était pas ça je ne sais pas mais
travaille juste pour répondre à fait
activé mvl aussi alors juste pour te
donner un ordre d'idée à wannsee l'an
dernier quand il y avait m vl donc c'est
un ton un mineur on va dire on était
entre six et dix mille tous les jours
pour le suivre cette année au norwich s
il ya un mois un tournoi de valeur égale
y avait cartonné tout ça on était entre
1800 et 3000 sur les live donc c'est le
même ratio qu'on a perdu entre revel et
alireza en fait il n'y a pas de
c'est l'effet de la perte de hype des
échecs dans le monde mais c'est pas le
fait qu'ils aient maxime qui joue pas en
fait il fait qu'il ya moins de monde qui
regarde c'est ça hein c'est juste c'est
fou de pas le
ne pas l'entendre
désolé femmes et c'est frustrant fait
que les gens
savent ouais en fait un jour vous pouvez
croire qu avril à les chiffres hisser
son métier il fait ça depuis des années
ben va pas vous inventer l'histoire pour
vous raconter une histoire mais après
ils voulaient pas croire vous croyez pas
en fait fin mai peut pas ramener sa
fraise dans le chatt pouvoir donner des
leçons quoi
m locindus trois bus de vue non non moi
je pense arrêter 10 10 ou 15% plus de
gens pas plus
après si on avait alireza ou maxime peu
importe que l'un des deux qui jouait le
gain du tournoi maintenant on serait
peut-être quinze ou vingt mille et elles
s'étaient alliés raison serait 18500
extrême actions seraient 21 minutes j'en
sais rien mais la différence c'est elle
et elle est assez minime en fait
et
et c'est comme ça mais juste vous prenez
des stades de choses qui se ressemblent
vraiment tu regardes le norwich chasse
avec maxime
kahn si tu vois que c'est deux ou trois
fois pain bon et c'était pareil à
bucarest et
et c'est comme ça en fait
mais c'est pareil dans les autres
langues etc fa c'est moins pire en
français que dans les autres langues
d'ailleurs mais c'est pareil partout
chat à free si perso c'est vrai que je
regarde de moins en moins les tournois
trop long au début j'étais hype mais ces
vitraux loubat c'est ça en fait c'est
que les gens ils ont c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué c'est que petit à petit les
gens ils ont compris
pour les ménages déjà nda on a été
trente mille plus pour les conserver
mais c'était à deux rondes de la fin on
était en première page sur twitter
français on avait eu un raid de stardock
et c'était la top chez mfr qui était
regardé donc en fait c'est un truc c'est
les algorithmes et exponentielle en fait
ce constat du monde qui vient ça te
rajoute du monde qui en rajoutent qui en
rajoute et qui monte mais déjà pour le
championnat du monde de blitz ou maxime
a gagné il est devenu champion du monde
du 800 m était déjà quinze ou seize
mille donc c'était déjà divisé par deux
par rapport aux candidats
et il avait gagné alors que candidat bon
après il ya peu c'était sur cette partie
n'est peau qui jouait quand même pour
beaucoup donc si on imagine un tournoi
où maxime faisait un résultat équivalent
à celui d'ali reza maintenant en fait on
serait pas trente mille la fin
il faut arrêter de raconter de penser à
n'importe quoi
est morte il est parti en fait face et
en fait c'est un fait on fait des là ce
sera ali reza qui joue le gain du
tournoi sur cette partie on serait là la
prochaine à jouer le gallia raisin on
serait peut-être quinze vingt mille je
sais pas mais battre mais pas 30 ans
fait et c'est pas une question plus que
maxime ou cali reza en fait ca c c'est
vous qui vous inventez des life en fait
c'est juste d'avoir un joueur français
bien classé et ou éventuellement 6 à
jouer encore le gain entre hikaru aînés
peau sur les prochaines rondes on serait
encore assez nombreux mais juste quand
un tournant et finit en fait il est fini
c'est tout
et c'était pareil pour les championnats
du monde il ya eu pas mal de monde pour
la partie qui a duré six heures ses
montées je pense à 14 15 mille
spectateurs aussi la partie était gagnée
les gens sont un peu revenus le
lendemain et en fait des queues n'est
pas perdu c'était pareil avec trois
quatre mille personnes
mais c'est comme ça en fait
mais c'est une question d'enjeu de
tournois de formats de beaucoup de
choses deux joueurs français de cadence
fin il ya beaucoup de trucs c'est comme
ces stats mondiale du coup le joueur
français américains hongrois ce que
voulait le jour on est plus de monde
mais monte à 12 mille personnes sur phil
rogers
nakamura en fait si phil rogers gagne
cette partie là qu'on est déjà douze
mille là qui commença à jouer le titre
c'est exactement la même dynamique et tu
vas monter à 15000 16000 17000 18 20 me
en fait c'est sûr tu vas monter en
puissance tous les jours mais en fait
s'ils commencent à perdre que tu as un
joueur qui s'échappe comme les peaux
quoi main plus personne ne regarde mais
j'imagine c'est pareil dans tous les
sports
ouais ça dépend moins des fans mais
justement la formule 1 si on connaît le
champion trois grands prix avant la fin
moi je n'avais pas regardé déjà je
regarde pas trop de base mais la
dernière version apple hamilton dans
le dernier tour de ouf machin fins et
voilà que j'y connais vraiment rien
et je pense à mais qui regarde jamais le
tennis il allume sa télé qui à deux sets
zéro deux breaks d'avancé dit oui groupe
j'éteins si il y à un set partout 5 5
dans le troisième virage tient bon vas-y
tu as que onze sages ou quoi bien sûr
bien sûr
oui c'est comme les l'époque qui
mesurait nous sommes sans voix quand il
écrasé le tour de la deuxième étape de
montagne moi je regardais je regardais
jamais mais je suis peut-être pas
représentatif du lambda mais parce que
le tour de france tu regardes aussi pour
les férias comme le côté paysage soir
quart de tour de france c'est très
spécifique mais oui ça a joué aussi mal
à les échecs c'est pareil en fait
c'est comme ça et c'est normal mais tu
mets maxime avec autant de points
qu'allié reza ça change rien et tu vas
tu vas sur le stream d'hikaru ya combien
de vies ils jouent c'est sa chaîne mais
pour le rugby c'est wendy sais pas en
fait genre j'ai un exemple avec mon père
oui et bien ri qui s'est couché à la 20e
minute parce qu'il ya déjà trois essais
à 0 pour montpellier à oui biensur
américain champcar où il ya 3000
personnes fait ya moins de monde que
pour un title tuesday enfin au bout d'un
moment et il joue le tournoi des
candidats c'est le plus gros tournoi du
monde ils sont 3000 à suivre sur sa
chaîne
moins que pour un title tune mais
nettement moins qu'un title tune et donc
à un moment donné ces écarts où il joue
et enfin c'est la règle pour les etats
unis c'est light maximum ils ont icaro
caruana qui se sont plus ou moins dans
l'ide encore et ils sont 21 milles sur
la chaîne en anglais quand tu sais
qu'ils ont beaucoup de premières pages
la fastueuse com et/ou 21000 pour eux
c'est vraiment très très peu ils ont
peut-être dit viens d'acheter au moins
cinquante mille
normalement oui oui mais bien sûr donc
en fait c'est mondiale
bref voilà c'est comme ça et
c'est pas grave mais c'est juste faut
arrêter d'inventer des choses en fait
mais là pour le coup pas voulu servir
vous fait vraiment croire qu'enfin vous
le prendre pour un clown des fois où
quoi mais là en fait il sait vraiment
mais
les personnes qui est le plus compétent
fait réellement
sérieux quoi donc un pour ça je suis
hyper compétent s'il ya bien une
compétence que j'ai c'est ça la la je le
connais très bien c'est tu peux voir des
mecs duchess comme qui me demander qui
m'écrivent alors cee censés être les
plus gros spécialistes mais ils peuvent
me demander ma plaie ce genre de
questions
mais à vrai le problème il est connu et
même et il va être très difficile à
régler à partir de maintenant parce que
les gens ont vraiment pris l'habitude de
dire que les échecs c'était de la merde
et ça va être très difficile c'est comme
jusqu'à main restaurant et a servi de la
merde pendant deux ans alors après
peut-être qu'ils vont jouer ils vont
bien mais jouer eux mais regardez les
tournants assez les tournois si là c'est
autre chose
faite le jeu en ne va pas été habillé
les règles sont restés les mêmes et si
les gens aiment bien jouer ils vont bien
mais jouer
mais
[Musique]
peut-être regarder ouais rester pendant
des live sur un tournoi comme le format
les a pas emballé et qui se sont
ouvertes isr ça c'est pas un tournoi
c'est 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 et au bout d'un
moment ça fait beaucoup
mais c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça et tant que temps un bon
le truc c'est que chaque chaque tournée
en plus comme ça c'est un nouveau
un départ de spectateurs en plus à
chaque fois ça creuse un petit peu
il revient pas au silence la différence
entre un joueur lambda non mais même
nous on regarde pas en fait si on
commande pas
donc non ce n'est pas une question
niveau c'est juste s'effacer l'on en
fait il fait quoi dink
sais pas mais c'est pas grave ou quoi
mais c'est juste que nier la réalité
c'est un vrai
coup il pouvait par ok donc il va tenter
roi f2 est passée la tour ils empêchent
cavalière 4,6 au passage passage
c'est un coup machin ne laissant que
trois
patrons g3 non mais il est très très mal
ligne
il va s'accrocher et puis si radio se
trouve pas peut-être sauvé de nuit ou
quoi mais ça sera pas mieux pour ding
que ça il sent le stream vous sied pas
non plus le tourner en sachant qu'il y
aurait à houta mais en fait on suit pas
on sait qu'il est il n'a en fait on
regarde les partis à la fin on passe de
temps en temps on va pas rester scotchés
devant enfin ça c'est sûr que non
je connais très peu de joueurs pros qui
sont scotchés devant les candidats on va
peut-être cornetto ce qui me disait
milliards il a beaucoup regardé tout ça
et là il a une oreille sur le truc il
faut tout mais bon là il ya le tour de
france qui a co qui a commencé il est
sur le tour de france très clairement et
c'est normal il paraît qu'ils vont
piloter au départ non
oui mais sert que tu regardes pas
vraiment en fait tu l'as lu mhz sur un
bus que deux côtés et touche quand on
dit regardez c'est regarder oui oui bah
voilà enfin si tu mets sans bruit de
fond et que tu vois là pendant la séance
tu dors ça passe la tondeuse
ont regardé cette redevance ben moi je
regarde un match de tennis
de foot je suis devant enfin je
vis mieux garde devant hogli chc la
première information du jour fab
il a fait des bulles est cette nuit où
on nous a dit que oui mais après je ne
sais pas dire on est déçus recueillies
aujourd'hui on se prend en photo mais en
tout cas son geste en cause c'est qu'il
fasse c'est catastrophique ce à dire que
c'est sûr que c'est ça avec vous mais
pas si grave encore mais bon c'est un
premier coup quoi c'est le truc c'est
que sa demande de duda trouver 4 mais
qui en fait il est hyper logique
je coupe pas envie de jouer quand même
ça c'est même pas un coup à trouver
c'est juste que tu joues loukou logique
mais non mais c'est pas ton joue pas
toujours le coup logique pour la peine d
france invente des life
ce qu'il répétera mais sa
distribution de points elo
à bâle s'ils
s'y fait pas f4 l'heure l'option de
faire plus tard mais j'ai rien enfin
c'est quand même l'occasion de se
séparer de ce b 2 très pénible quoi
bah c'est plutôt le feinter plutôt
content dé changer ça c'est ça avec les
blancs d'esprit tu t'en débarrasser en
plus tu vas faire roi atteinte tu vas te
mettre sur cases blanches et tu va taper
sur la colonne gc hyper logique
à savoir s'ils allaient caillage 5 des
trucs qui vont venir un peu dans les
pattes des blancs mais en soi
devant la tête qui d'autre notre ami
duda
il a l'air plutôt content et en plus le
truc qui est dommage pour ali reza là
c'est qu'en fait si tu fais ce coup là
et que je parle on va dire sept sur dix
dans le tournoi girouard il est chaud et
tout mais en fait quand à la tête sous
l'eau tu fais que des parties de mer de
maintien il re craque encore
bon après qui sait ça va donner un jeu
compliqué vous n'avez pas en grande
forme non plus hein je crois qu'ils se
partagent la dernière place des années
tout seul derrière ouais bon mais il
n'est pas très loin n'en doutons pas
soldat il a gagné cinq rangs du carreau
l'intégrant dans ce qu il ya de gens
restés à 2 j'aurais moi ça ils étaient
revenus 1,4 et il a fait nul hier il a
il a réussi à dépasser
les pressions de l'étranger après minuit
rien ce soir mais en fait les gens
disent qu'ils avaient surtout chasse
comme et pallie chess cette nuit mais je
sais pas si c'est vrai il faudrait
revoir son pseudo tu fais comme si vous
des partis
faire nous mais j'ai pas son coach est
là
je sais pas si c'est vrai ou pas après
il a aussi pu jouer sur un pseudo cacher
pour un deuxième pilote officiel s'il
dit rien à personne il faisait partie
j'aurais joué sur czech comme contre
bolton propos d'eric en scène dont six
séries qui l'a dit on peut le croire
eric 1ere qu'ils racontent pas de
conneries ce truc là
1ere
pas de bêtises sur son pseudo mais n'y a
pas joué depuis le 22 avril 2021 mais
d'avoir un autre se doit
du coup truc si je connais pas tous ces
pseudos moins
investi eric l'a écrit
la prairie ko quelques férus qui peut
jouer ainsi on le travail est à ce
niveau bande c'est juste que ça va être
un compte caché
mais on s'en fout un peu au passage ben
non c'est quand même important fin j'ai
passé un chauffeur qui joue on regarde
sa partie ce qu'il a fait cette nuit ça
peut influer dessus s'est pas
complètement hors sujet 1
10 simpl the beast surchasse colle sur
czech comme
ce pseudo l'a
apparemment ce serait lui
un check point com
recherche s 1
mg le jazz the best avec 1 1 à la place
du village
porte pas forcément bien son nom en ce
moment bon après il un drapeau norvégien
think the beast
l'autre un autre votre un saumon
ouais mais il a peut-être fait ça pour
brouiller les pistes oui il va bien sûr
tu mèneras bout que tu veux oui
avant le 1er juillet c'est une info qui
les jeunes faire des petites recherches
il a beaucoup je le prends
même pas de doute pas
je peux ne pas deux
cellules en sus magnus ouais
mais non
parti hier
en classe menée l'an iv fab c'est pas un
peu ou très actif un cercle hier il a
joué pour deux pages de partie et tu
reviens avant il ya eu deux parties le
26 mai
juste 2 ça ressemble avant ça va en
octobre 2021 quoi ça ressemble à ça
quand même
ça ressemble à tielt encore cette nuit
on y perd bugatti heures il a joué
contre knvb donc il devait savoir si
c'est vrai mais c'est pour ça eric non
c'est pas ça faisait des bonds du coup
moi je fais confiance à eric sur un truc
comme ça
beaucoup je compte qu'elle rêvait
deux matches où
je faisais que ça leur pseudo debra
qu'en fait c'est que celui dans les
pieds ont besoin absolu de chasse bras
je pense qu' aux deux pieds ou que et
ricky d'avoir un pinceau et rick hansen
un pseudo pour ammann
c'est pour ça que ça ressemble à ça il
s'est fait défoncer un match énorme qui
a joué qui a duré deux pages de partie
je sais pas quand ça qu'orange est de
dire exactement j'ai joué compétion je
crois qu'il y avait il ya vingt parties
par page
ok donc je re lire page 2 ça commence là
après celle ultra bullet c'est pas
énorme 1 40 parties seraient vite un
scénar
donc enfin l'évolution du score partie
une
victoire null null victoires/défaites +1
+20 plus sain plus de lustre qui peut
faire leur historique de 1 vient de
taper nom de l'adversaire knvb
ah mais nous aussi ça nous amuse qu'il
fasse n'importe quoi en ligne attention
hein on est plutôt heureux c'est marrant
cette façon le tournoi est terminé
maintenant moi je préfère qu'il fasse
cadeau à tout le monde que ça fasse un
genre de
bain je suis pas trop après comment je
fais pour soir le score entre les je
sais pas comment on fait
je compte truc par trop d'exceptions
bonds
importants j'ai eu beaucoup de parties
pour deux ans les chiens sont quatre ils
pèsent le pour le contre
bon après c'est que
après tout ça comme chez isr il n'est
pas fins pas forcément le joueur le plus
en confiance non plus un
laveur un truc cacher quoi je sais pas
cf 4g fgf des quatre vu que ce truc de
en fait ce retour prends tu vas
collègues de mme b 6
voilà tu fais c'est 5 et à garder tombé
2 alors tu es content d'avoir verger je
veux dire mais c'est peut-être moins
grave que oui mais ça va quand même
enfin c'est quand même une version
améliorée que d'avoir à moi j'aurais vu
un truc comme ça mes lordi donne pas
donc mais bon
la barre sa joue
tu dis tu resteras tanger 3 du coulis ce
machin mais oui non mais il doit y days
il doit le faire se fie qu'à trois mois
je parle alors d'un égal aux gens
l'impression d'être beaucoup bien que
blanc
s'est trompé dans les vals
clairement fille rousse et le même
pattern il a utilisé un pseudo vue qui
s'est fait taper sur les doigts et r'way
ça ressemble enfin la pro b vie en
glucides en scène qui connaît bien sûr
où il a beaucoup joué et qui coexiste
ils se ressemblent pas tarder fin
dans la position a priori c'est lui
après y'a pas de preuves tangibles
et knvb c'est à vannes on bolton un bras
rien de très forte coïncidence après il
n'y a pas de preuves
un bûcher pour enquêter sur le terrain
et
c'est ça qui nous faudrait
qui bat pour empêcher f4 leblanc en fait
si l'on fait j'ai trois c'est pour faire
un sketch assez souhaité continuer à
avancer
mais ça n'empêche pas donc oui ça que
c'est pas un coup terrible parce que si
tu prends prend prend battu père lui à
la place alors après ok layton qui avait
attaqué je pense que tu en fais tu
bouges quoi mais en gros toutes ces
colonnes qui sauve c'est plutôt cool
pour les blancs et une diagonale là il
ya une tour qui peut coulisser je sais
pas te des rois changer un jour mais
attention à ça si tu mêleront un chien
pour l'instant tu fais retour des trois
tu perds ton rêve 3 tu va doubler je
sais pas a abondé choses comme ça mais
effectivement le roi noir a l'air plus
en danger que celui-là même si les deux
sont ouverts
donc tu veux ça donne ça vienne des
attaques sur la colonne et les blancs au
2e tour contre une donc
bah disons oui ça existe pour faire fou
des quatre et c5 et autant faire ça
maintenant bah oui il y aura ça tu fais
shake your browser quand bien même la
variante là ça et je sais pas là
peut-être
il a oui bas moins il ya ception plutôt
que tout à l'heure où ils sont prêtes à
5 ans à ba oui et non ça fait aucun sens
en fait trop que c'est sûr c'est pas un
bon coup j'ai
bien non des preuves hier c'est
aujourd'hui qu'on a pas de preuve qu'il
a fait 4 derrière c'est officiel c'est
son pseudo c'est son pseudo est là
jusqu'à 5h 45 14 45 du match était plus
donc
[Musique]
derrière c'est enfin la nuit avant-hier
c'est officiel c'est pour ça que pour le
gard la critique est
hélas va on se doute que séduit quoi
critiquer ou pas critiquer peu importe
il fait ce qu'il veut et ça arrive mais
à priori oui c'est pas la préparation
idéale pour une partie de haut niveau
mais d'un autre côté c'est bien si le
fait jusqu'au bout parce que ça met un
peu les autres sur un pied d'égalité par
rapport à sa vie oui c'est ça je fais
tout le temps complet au monde et voilà
c'est bien
qu'ils aient tours 8 bref deux dames
bedouet bombe très bien donc c'est de la
grande souffrance pour ding je sais pas
s'il va arriver à tenir ou pas cette
partie allait une nouvelle fois c'est un
bon défenseur
objectivement ça va pas du tout
mais les gens ont vraiment fouiller pour
trouver sa maison pas eu besoin de
fouiller puisqu'il a joué contre à manom
bolton qui est chez ce bras qui est
connu non qu'ils n'ont pas à fouiller
ses justes et ricky et l'autre chaise
bras qui le dit et enfin personne à
fouiller pour trouver ça c'est jusque
là ils jouent en direct sur un stream
quoi il ya des gens qui regardent
le crâne ce disque affirmant qu une
compréhension stratégique boiteuse est
vraiment un manque de respect barré
donc oui et non le dans le sens où c'est
un manque de respect c'est parce que ça
a été son coach c'est ton coach on sait
pas que c'est fini ou pas mais ils ont
fait des sessions de travail ont vu des
candidats ensemble à mon avis s'est fait
défoncer hier
et il a dit ça aujourd'hui un la
ressemble la vengeance quand même
cech brasser une chaîne chef bras c'est
le nom du très long du truc way
chaîne de très connue depuis très
longtemps
j'ai une dizaine d'années qui sont là
pas passionné parti aujourd'hui
honnêtement c'est ouais mathieu va
sûrement nous dire que c'est de très
belles parts ici et là mais je suis pas
sûr aujourd'hui quoi
non ça ça doit intéresser d'un point de
vue théorique parce que c'est oui oui un
jeu qui va gueuler mais en fait ce qu'a
fait digne pas trop digne d'intérêt quoi
enfin c
est que il a mal géré l'ouverture dont
qui se retrouve très mal avec les blancs
en quinze coups
et
alors caruana on n'a pas trop regarder
ça sert une partie entre les battues est
ok et duda firoud jab d'attirer
l'intérêt théorique mais la g55
quoi
donc là aujourd'hui se joue pas très
bien non après c'est compréhensible mais
c'est qu'on dise avant
répu la machin
non c'est juste digne six paires celles
là qui pourraient s'en mordre les doigts
puisque je comprends qu'ils jouent bien
mais là on n'a même pas vu où il a joué
bien dans la partie et donc au pire tu
peux essayer de sceller la nuit a écrit
blanc estampillé de ses devises est la
seconde place qui normalement sert à
rien mais où l'attend un petit espoir
tout à fait fabien
bon tour une pause
après la pub ouais on peut refaire une
petite pub oui tout à fait bien vu fab
on va laisser la caméra sur dean qui
essayent de lutter et on va faire une
petite pause
août à tout
bayonne est coupable
est partie sans que ding soit
complètement foutue entre 3 c en terrine
vraiment le tournant instant prendre
joueurs seront à prendre sur mater en
fait ces cinq way to the matter barrois
des trois épreuves cinq j'imagine
finito ice est finie tôt pour ding peu
abandonné
a pas une bonne partie
voilà c'est bien sa clôture un tournoi
intéressant
là ça fait vraiment deux points d'écart
mais on ne peut vraiment dire sans aucun
souci que
la fin sera pas encore finie
officiellement
mais il ya vraiment plus le l'once
d'intérêt qui existaient encore à suivre
ces partis est parti
d'un grand père s on le voit il tire sur
sa manche
partie raté
pas on aura encore deux jours un noir
suivre dimanche et lundi on vous en veux
pas si vous venez pas
en fait faites comme vous voulez
[Musique]
et duda fier où aller on peut bailler
pas très bien fillon l'a jugé cinq
matches joués malawi en plus il avait
même pas le coût des quatre heures
mais bon le truc c'est que le tour des
candidats sa fin les intérêts qui
pourraient avoir ce serait de voir des
belles parties mais enfin là se sont pas
départies intéressantes à regarder ça
jour en boulettes
un peu mais franchement en trois
puissants tu peux avoir des partis à
passer équivalente un hug 5 et 10 à jet
f4 à merde ça marche mais c'est vrai
qu'en partie lente
ben ouais y'a pas grand intérêt à
attendre jadis 2h30 de jeu pour pourvoir
ce à quoi qui est plutôt du niveau on va
dire allez en 15 + 10 est encore parti
mal joué de 15 + 10 quand même avec les
noirs
wayne rooney puis banni ding ne nous
avait pas habitués à ça
ouais peut-être fatigués des joies ouais
il a du kram ada aujourd'hui
méconnaissable
brasser les parties
bon après c'est mieux d'en faire une
comme ça une bonne fois pour bien
bien purgée quoi la presse qui voit
écailler reza c'est que c'est tous les
jours
allawi
carlson 11 du cne peau gagne ou pas
banner peau est pas officiellement donc
il attendra que ce soit officiel il
reste deux parties fo qui marque enfin
un demi point sur deux et que je compte
d'ailleurs à porte
avec un blanc bon c'est dans ses cordes
john deere & co a d'ailleurs bien même
en fait il fait enfin même s'il faisait
0 sur deux je pense que personne ne veut
faire 2 sur 2 derrière façon
bravo à lui on l'a déjà dit ouais bah
idole
il a surpassé les attentes je veux dire
très bien franchement cela fera
peut-être son traumatisme 2013
c'est vrai quand le tournant on donnait
pas cher de sa peau surtout son tourne à
bucarest qui était horrible mais il a
montré que ben justement ils jouent pas
dans la méta d'esprit quand ça compte là
il a vraiment voilà c'est bien ce qu'il
a fait c'est pour ça qu'on vieillit note
souvent aussi que les tours
qualificatifs aux candidats et les
tournois de type grande chez ce tour
c'est pas du tout la même chose en fait
pas de même niveau de jeu c'est parce
pas la même chose du tout
beaucoup de surprises
oui et non en fait enfin le nippo gagne
c'est pas non plus une surprise
incroyable
il aurait pu ou pas voilà d'adding dans
le groupe d second quart des groupes d
second dacca après duda rapporte qui
souffrent s'attendent à un peu moi je
pensais donc du courage à la plus
jouée sur des circonstances après la
déception et ali reza moment le seul
joueur qui surprend vraiment faim qui
est vraiment pas loin de ce qu'on de ce
qu'on pense c'est firoud déjà et celui
qui surprend bien de ce qu'on pense et
c'est et rajab of en fait une époque un
qui survole un dépôt qui survolerait qui
gagne le tournant soit way est une
possibilité mais qu'il écrase à ce point
de tourner un
cavalier h5 menace rien b vitraux h à
priori oui mais mon tour f 3 rue et
wattrelos
j8 aurait feint et tu vas te faire
pilonner f7 et oui tu parle absolument
n'importe quoi ce qui fait c'est
exceptionnel
d'accueil
pour moi non vache doit tourner qui joue
pas trop mal mme banon elle a émis avec
va dans ce qu'ils peuvent au début de
l'année mis entre la place 4 et 6 il va
peut-être finir entre 3 mai entre trois
et cinq jeux c'est pas une grosse
surprise en fait
[Musique]
finir deux
filles on avec la remplace par ces
candidats je suis pas d'accord mais
s'est qualifiée pour moi tous les
joueurs qui sont caduques s'ils avaient
leur fasse il sous-performe mais il a sa
place avec 0 3 mondial et il s'est
qualifié donc voilà après ici la manne
jouer mais il n'a pas volé sa place
enfin il a volé à personne
mais là il joue mal c'est tout
et il a en plus et là en plus il va la
jouer un peu comme dépôt dans son match
mais le seul truc aller qu'on a trouvé
deux
discutable dans ce qu'il fait c'est une
époque ont-ils fait n'importe quoi bon
gars n il se pénalise que lui il faut
savoir qu'un arrêt fit rouler dans un
tournoi où en fait si field et des
points à intel et pas un autre ça change
le classement final
donc en fait se tirer des balles
manquées soi-même son taux punir
j'entends sur douvres un mano à mano
bakar scène qui annonceront dans dix
rondes en deux rondes à la fin tu as
perdu et c'est des points d'eau at war
mais voilà bon après il se trouve que
d'avoir des prières ou pas ça n'a pas
changé la qualif de nemo mai
par respect partie collecte tu peux te
dire moi je fais mon maximum même si là
je peux pas grand chose au piège fait
nul avec les blancs de justesse le jeu
quénard je m'accroche terrain de 80 ans
tu perdras parce que tu vois vraiment
rien tu appelles ça vous qui marche et
ça arrive aussi à tout le monde pressent
et bars en fout pas par exemple il n'a
pas fuit la digue ça fait une énorme
différence en fait le fils a dit non
et oui papa le point d'eau il déjà moins
he has trois parties dont celles là qui
pouvait perdre il pas très bien donc oui
enfin c'est cinq points par cinq points
chaque jour
encore je retourne mais il avait joué
avec les blancs à l'aller j'avais pas
donné
on peut importe c'est le format qui est
comme ça on a déjà parlé plein de fois
les formats match ça donne une
compétition plus intensive est pas moins
équilibrée entre guillemets
équitable
c'est juste plus équitable et plus
intéressant à suivre après c'est ce
format là qui a été choisi pour les
raisons qu'on connaît de chèques
équitable
ce qui passait un clown jour pas
vraiment mais c'est juste que tu sais
que c'est un de ses points faibles et
que et que tu pourras
potentiellement misé dessus dans
d'autres tombent ainsi commença à perdre
il peut complètement explosé et les
jours avant le savoir et vont essayer de
et se ressemblent ils seront sans pitié
way
jusqu'à ce qui règle le problème
arsène pas je souhaite rendre dépôt il a
aucun intérêt particulier c'est juste
qu'il n'a pas envie je crois mais il n'y
a pas d'intérêt
ça fait peut-être chien en fait juriste
mais c'est aussi ça le fait chier c'est
tout ça va pas plus loin il n'y a pas
intérêt à chercher derrière ou quoi ce
que
mais bon pour moi c'est assez
il joue pas il sera plus champion du
monde et point barre ah oui enfin je
n'aime pas que pour toi c'est
officiellement le cas et
et
il se retient de lui même quoi
fil rouge avait pas trop vieux pour
régler ce genre de problème alors un nom
et puis en plus tu peux avoir une
carrière à très haut niveau avec ce
problème il suffit juste de jamais faire
de mauvais tournant comme magnus par
exemple ouais non les jardins époux il a
plus ou moins de problèmes oui mais
voilà je vois tu l'as pas vu quoi
tu vas pas le voir puisqu'il va juste
réussir des tournants importants sauf
quand il tombe sur plus fort mais le
match contre carl scène je pense que si
tu choques pas complètement c'est la
même après il perdra un peu moins cher
mais perdrait quand même donc
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment pas départi
palpitant de cons suis
fait plaisir pour tout à ça lui remet un
petit punto ça le remet en milieu de
tableau
nous attendions
tous nous dit que la dernier entaillé
beaucoup avec cinq coups sur le niveau
de jeu cette année y en a des bien pires
que les
batailles et je sais même pas non avec 5
go c'était un peu vraiment le petit
poucet du tournoi et je pense c'est pas
lui faire un joueur qui jouera plus
jamais de tort à des candidats de sa vie
il a eu il a pris sa chance quand il a
pu il a fait 3e du truc etc mais
et après lui pour ses standards il a
fait son tendre en fait il a vraiment
donné le max c'était correct mais tu
gardes le tour vous avez dit oui dexia
plus intéressant sa part des candidats
un côté tôt crassat c'était sûr tour de
france au dessus
puis voici bingo vraiment un choix
bénéfique gauche parlait de l'iccn
alexine courir ici piankov hausse est
plus jeune mais sa mauvaise - là ça sent
aussi
j'avais un cours avant m
pendant ton tour tu regardes le tour de
france
nous sachions mathieu
ben firoud là il va perdre combien de
points ainsi perd encore aujourd'hui la
soie 25 c'est beau non ouais
pas mal de sélections en tournant 20
et 25
25 c'est beau et c'est segura jawhar
fait il plante ida kaeding pour la fin
pour
ce que ding a abandonné en fait
alors la position et digne d'amont ah
non oui mais non il vient de faire
qualité un
bon bah il va jouer qu'un pur - un roi
faible la paire de fous
[Musique]
moi savoir
alors ton âme c'était une pièce d'échec
sur la croix-valmer xgd pièces d'échecs
sur un pion pas ses protégés pas mal
ouais le pire
c'est beau un pion pas assez protégé
je me mettrais bien
tout est parti de sa victoire contre
magasins ou centres non non je pense qu
à rien qu'ils allaient parce que déjà
contrat porte il devait perdre et
c'était avant je pense que globalement
il aurait fait un bond après ça aurait
pu changer des choses et machin mais en
gros
il ya eu un problème dans la prépa
pour gars de char deuxième temps
10 gouttes quoi
ça commence déjà
à déjà écrasé le tour quoi
ces genres de nespouls à
vélo
une partie au soutien du monde dès le
début car scène personnage phare de la
merci non enfin
mais non droit mieux par contre niveau
il sera en confiance et magnus bas il
aime pas de derrière et de la fin donc
oui ça nous mettra moins à l'aise mais
il va pas tilté ai donné les paroles
match sera du 50 50 dans ce cas là j'ai
signé pose comment premier ca devien 50
50 et si magnus corps en premier c'est
catherine 18,2 ouais c'est ça le truc
c'est le gros problème pour reprendre
les prophètes
option qui est la première partie enfin
après ça le premier joueur à gagner dans
le match
et c'est dur de battre car la scène dans
les matchs on vient du monde il n'a plus
perdu depuis 2007 d'une partie
[Musique]
ce match c'est ainsi le cas pour moi
n'est peu de vent dans les six premières
c'est exactement ça fait ouais mais le
truc c'est qu'en match en fait c'est
tellement important non mais c'est ça
votre nez pour y jouer bien et ses
premières enfin juste il ya pas de cette
partie marathon et
disparitions
presse qu'il avait le bon passeur
train demande
ma soeur avec soin des peaux c'est bon
il ya quand même beaucoup progresser
bien travaillé il a bien
sans parler d'amy sène de là bas c'est
fini c'est pourquoi je crois qu'il n'est
pas content du mercato
l'image me casse il est parti tiao les
ploucs ouais alors que oui le club
allait bien les effets 2d etc et c'est
un génie quand même
ça lui encore après avec les présidents
au recours achète tous les clubs sur
gueye l'euromillions ces terribles
façon ces actes et sa femme ainsi on
gagne l'euro millions ce soir on fait
une offre à ses intérêts ont fait une
après on ira de nouveau président ici
présent et c'est beau quoi
donc sur un tueur abbas et 193 millions
d'euro millions non pour mes 50 sur
sainté on est encore bien on est encore
bien mais on en voit aussi 20 sur le
mercato voilà pour essayer de remonter
baky entraîneur ce serait magnifique en
fait un bail qui sur le banc
on avait une super idée quoi on va
recruter des joueurs type ba qui
pour faire des bouts de matchs dès fois
ça serait beau faire entrer baky ans lee
jang quoi
pas celle à rome on ne veut pas à
l'image à remonter en ligue 1
et puis puis petit à petit on va bâtir
un truc très très bien impôts staff ça
très intéressant baky pas sa visite
médicale facile
c'est beaucoup mais qui sera un joueur
de brandao
l'afsset devant et ajusté à tacler tout
le monde quoi y'en a absolument rien à
[ __ ]
je pense c'est un monde dubaï qui met un
but j'ai pas genre je sais pas il est
bien placé et d'un gris
normalement non mais faut vraiment du
bol quoi faut vraiment un corner ça
rebondit enfin
moi je postulerai pour faire peut-être
un petit bout de match du gardien très
bonne idée mathieu mais j'imagine la
tête de ba qui s'ils marquent c'est pas
possible
[Rires]
même un péno fort bien de s'entraîner
pour le premier c'est
bidon je pensais très très dur en fait
le go là ils sont vraiment pas ils sont
forts et maintenant ils ont ici parce
que ça part fort est pressé et s'ils
savent que c'est un plot qui attirait il
a bien assez de bouvier ses cages et la
dépression de ton corps à voir ce que tu
fais voilà bah merci
donc
devoir faire de gros entraînements de
tir au but
ce sont eux le dira t on votera impérial
sur les penaltys
web à qui je pense qu'il a vraiment joué
le buteur
wade françois bien solide le très claire
est derrière elle et où plus très clair
mais je pense qu'on était vraiment
mauvais défenseur si beaucoup vu ses
équipes en danger avec le hors jeu le
match à d'ailleurs gelé devant arriver
en
bas qui rentre avec 4 un événement est
je pense un match où on mène 3-0 ils
rentrent même à la 80e quoi
très beau que suivre officie le maillot
il est là c'est une vraie saute
avec son numéro 22 a un numéro 22
évidemment
oui maso serait déjà plus sérieux
bazot il peut déjà plus marqué mais son
pointu sa grosse frappe allemande de
loin
tre 23 à
[Rires]
83 déjà pris
i'm 593 millions c'est un commando l'eau
sale si vous ne voyez pas dimanche
peut-être que en tractation pour acheter
des seize
mois je pense qu'on va être direct à
sainté en fait
ce qu'on voit une cramique
jouer de ta peut-être sur les corners
intégrant tient l'asie
une chance sur glace je craque c'est en
fait je pense que c'est une chance sur
193 millions d'ailleurs on arrive 40 non
c'était plus de dix ans 40 minutes
plus tôt récents 39 millions de têtes
une chance sur beaucoup
pour combien pour les bonus et les
échecs beaucoup un numéro en occupera
aussi en parallèle de s mais peut-être
20 à 30 millions on a des belles idées
ouais
on fera double double truc
d'ailleurs on pourra faire jouer un
tournoi d'échecs à geoffroy guichard ah
bah oui
avec les ultras dans le stade trop
chaque coup
[Musique]
dur sur 33 milliard tu le dis c'est
vieillot
plusieurs jets pas nous a sorti 3 je
sais pas moi j'ai pas on arrive sur
google c'est ce qu'il écrivait mais
c'est peut-être que les 5 numéros des
travailleurs
je
tarif on regarde jouer déguisant los
feliz environ 130 millions ce qu'on
allait trouver
et ce serait bottari déguisé en mode
partenariat vlc en fait ouais et
sponsors on s'enlise et vlc pas du tout
bon fait jouer tu titularisant ligue 1
tu es vraiment un vrai un maillot plots
quoi le défenseur central
femmes on a toutes nos chances
une chance sur cent trente millions
c'est vrai que c'est pas lourd mais bon
je suis mais en plo de corner quoi c'est
beau à tulle titulariser tulle mais
là-bas quoi
soit un autre chiffre
comme ça mais il semblait logique les
chances mais peut-être à 5 chance
d'avoir le premier numéro sur diviserait
stata d'ordre à ses pattes a pas
forcément de bon ordre et
théories d'or bachir où il joue
tellement mal la
crs incroyable de jouer aussi mal en
fait
statistiquement il ya plus de chances de
mourir sur le trajet jusqu'au bureau de
tabac que gagner à l'euro millions
c'est vrai en plus
ça va la voiture nous
met même à mon avis
ce corps les plus pures et oui citoyens
plus de coups en fait
ses proches d'abandon déjà je pense
peut-être pas ce point mais outre m à
nos fatwas mais bon ça ne peut en vue
d'analyser puisque je sais pas comment
dire mais il a pourri sa position tout
seul en cas de coup et c'est pas digne
d'une partie longue en fait
j'aime ça aurait pu faire mieux que
cheyrou sur ce tournoi beau monde au
total soit l'auteur 38 elle aurait
peut-être autant de points ont perdu
autant de parties mais en jouant mieux
puis ça a été plus méritantes sylla 150
probablement un quasiment fait
c'est intentionnel sapin en justice il
en tilt et il peut plus jouer une partie
du jeu d'échec c'est tout en fait 25 ans
qu'on nous demande crois que ça marche
pas trop aidé à me prendre à mes torts
f5
double attaque
et voilà
nom d'un médecin ne soulage pas vraiment
vous soulagé ça pourrait finir plus vite
moins de souffrance dont cet échiquier
mais sinon en soi pour la position en
elle même soit pas grand chose
ouais non c'est le niveau de jeu est
famélique là c'est
ridicule ce trois jours
gensse
se faire foudroyer
causerait pas plus de tumeurs pas
forcément foudroyé
la foudre elle peut te connecter des
pouvoirs
et les autres bien vous savez pas
vraiment plus d'intérêt alors en fait
appartient à roanne à ça joue vraiment
pour rien donc bon c'est au moins ça une
partie normale c'est une perte au
malmont difficile de regarder juste et
celle là qu'il ya un enjeu bon près 23
coup les blancs ont un peu moins et sont
complètement foutu c'est assez ridicule
comme l'autre n'ont la ya vraiment plus
rien plus rien à voir
s'il y avait un super pouvoir va dans le
sens où j'aime beaucoup les échecs moi
ce serait pour accélérer le temps
explique deux minutes je joue
je pense cette foire qui me serait le
plus utile dans la vie au quotidien et
toi femme et a pas le pouvoir
intéressant
téléportation
s'écoule
lire les pensées ah non ça je pensais
infernale au dessus des listes envie pas
tentant tout tout le temps où tu deviens
fou si tu veux
tu as envie hein parce que j'ai cités ça
va sinon tu t'entends des
dvd mais je suis enceinte doit être fou
moi je pense je préfère le
répartition
et la non je suis là ferait bouger les
objets à distance sympa
volées volées ou pas
mais bon tant qu'à faire autant de
talent et portails quoi fin fut
encore plus immédiat quoi mes volets
sympa et un peu avec les oiseaux à date
je peux te dis partez dans le ciel tu
vas ou de chute libre tout heurter les
pareil
pourquoi pas forcément
il ya invisibilité qui peut être
intéressant est vrai parce que moi mais
comment tu fais si tu veux faire
la même chose tu veux faire pense
téléportation moi j'aime bien
les choses en art
bratu vous téléporte j'irai le chercher
alors si j'ai besoin qu'on
prête
co 6
voire de guérison
c'est bon pour toi même et pour les
autres surtout
ça des pouvoirs
pouvoirs de régénérescence aussi mais
guérison c'est mieux parce qu'au moins
tu veux profiter les autres ouais
voyage dans le temps
mais ça peut être galère tu perds tu
fais tu te rends compte qu'il ya
beaucoup de pouvoir qui en plus vous
êtes gens le temps vallée un truc ça
arrive jamais dans les films je veux
dire jusqu'à ce temps c'est que ce n'est
pas un endroit où à dans la gueule d'un
dinosaure fini ou eilat et sur mer il
n'y avait pas d'immeuble sur la route
paraît ont versé enfin
lacie vous téléporte dans le temps tu
sais pas je sais pas si je suis là sur
une chaise
super pouvoir d'achat aussi
le pouvoir d'achat
jusqu'à plein d'objets sans fil
[Musique]
stéphanie fille de marie
cécile vieux ouais c'est vieux mais
c'est tellement bien ouais
ont dégénéré de way
vous parlez de the boss 2h stream et des
épisodes avant-hier je crois je sais pas
si c'est à moi de le faire avec
tweet choix tu partie
des fois tu as le droit de diffuser les
trucs qu'elle regarde avec la commune
spoil
mais du coup d'épisodes les gens voient
l'épisode aussi mais il faut qu'ils
aient amazon prime oui et tu commentes
en même temps tu peux où tu peux juste
regarder je regarde tout ça dans mon
coin quoi
c'est amazon prime ça va passer mais
après il car vous avez les droits
d'auteur s'est pas
non plus toujours personne la plus
respectueuse du travail des artistes
c'est beau le coût de la vie hors achat
c'est complètement débile
mais on donne trois ou quatre échecs
dames g2a d'échangés après tu
n'y as pas le faire
tu laisses aussi kg 3 rebonds adam g
doit primer mais du coup ça fait
tellement de trucs bizarres en un je
sais même pas si le coup tu le vois pas
quoi
mais ça serait beau là ça serait la
symphonie la prophylaxie rater cette
sortie ski à g5 qui empêche la f4 et ça
veut c'est ce visage des annonciades
c'est
l'anti prophylaxie qu'on en fait
c'est quoi le problème de tours f4 c'est
cavalli prend en fait ouais et tanger
trois quarts il existe maintenant
[Musique]
rien à dire j'aime plus quoi dire en
fait
je
serai votre farine fiesta quoi
l'autre jour de bullet ça se passe pas
trop bien quoi
il n'a pas trouvé
alors qu'il est censé redonner l'égalité
au noir quasiment il ramène le feu sacré
est
[Musique]
assez hallucinant là attendant juste
pour ma gouverne roy chef au sein et que
c'est quoi le problème est peut-être
marre un petit chien fou juste damev
devrait
donc tu as pris ta case août adam g 2 tu
as pris ta case
est apparu a pas vu le courage 1
mais ouais 5 ou quoi là pour le coup dur
à voir mais par par esprit de tient il à
fait j'ai 500 objets pas efficace qui
après intègre là pour qu'ils trouvent un
coup quoi ton
plaisir
pour après écoute c'est pas un coup dit
bill 3 2 c'est pas le meilleur mais
c'est pas débile les blancs sont quand
même mieux 1
on prend juste un coup bah non ben oui
c'est un coup la montre à l'instant un
jeu guerrier prend toujours et qui a
rédigé ce qui revenait à pranger 6
défendre la colonie
regard un peu roland la espada roland
bras wimbledon il se passe quoi
je vois possible des trucs sur le tourne
quand je regardais indirecte la
thiam n'a 15e temps provisoire cana il
est pas mauvais je crois
quelle quelle vidéo ce soir
on va voir à l'oubli qui parle a déjà
fait savoir la miniature il faut qu'on
lui dise aujourd'hui on fait la partie
de fuir ou non mais je sais pas enfin
non ces pandas place d'un
régime jean ghio gagne
on peut prévoir en france en miniature
on mettra en ligne on fera pas de nature
après il peut on faire une pourront
faire une
citation
n'est pas sûr mais en fait c'est que
juste qu'on peut pas savoir
c'est pas très grave après un
fait salle de néo pop art après tout
façon on dira que les peaux un beau
champion
on attendra peut-être que ce soit
officiel pour faire la dernière vidéo
carlson nepomniachi le retour
a dit je n'ai pas bien
imaginer très mal mais
c'est terminé un mmorpg créé la surprise
car c'est la direction qui ne rejouera
pas contre mais pau c'est pas du genre à
dire des paroles en l'air ou là et on a
dit des choses qui l'a pas suivi
on verra à agir s'ils jouent pas ils
jouent bas enfin
s'ils décident de jeu et finalement ils
jouent à vendre et fait ce qu'il veut en
fait
il veut jouer il joue il veut pas jouer
je vous parle salif sa carrière que oui
son héritage
sera plus champion du monde et puis
enfin c'est arrivé à d'autres
bassins magnus à dijon qui a pas su
comme quoi plus bas je crois qu'il ya
plus de dix ans il qu'ils voulaient
chance il était champion du monde et
changer le format
jamais fait quoi fauvez 5 jouer au
hockey bien le firo
mais après il suivrait sa logique de
base ce qui ne met pas trop ce truc deux
matches déjà au début oui l'a jamais
mais en fait
les mises hors de prix mais en fait elle
n'a pas le pouvoir de pouvoir changer de
format pas quand tu es champion du monde
tu as quand même ben c'est comme l'a en
fait ils jouent pas mais ils proposent
rien donc c'est pas du tout constructif
un nom mais bon peu importe en fait moi
je m'en fous complètement qui joue pas
en fait j'en fais aussi rien à [ __ ] je
pense c'est juste mieux et plus logique
floue mais après tu vois je vois on sait
ça fait comme il veut franchement
si je vous passe interdit final on
l'avait su elle est déjà enterré
méthodique ça change plus rien en fait
je joue pas il joue pas fin pour moi ya
pas mort d'homme un bon ces matches ils
sont pas très intéressant mais ça se
trouve pour un effet secondaire que tu
es caron par hasard qui est deuxième des
combats et que du coup à jouer avec les
gens seront tues ricard ou et parle
entre autre chose me dit que c'est bien
c'est pas bien opportun
ouais non elle est partie aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment mauvais
c'est la vraie termes de qualité c'est
de loin la pierre journée
desservi
ording radjabov
c'est la cata
14 pour ding voit qu'elle aura faible
qui répond de moins
d'âme attaqués s'ils se cachent
mais va perdre le fou en fait peut-être
qui tacle à tour
attaque la tour parce qu'il prend pions
et l'a peut-être aussi
piles
d'ordures
bim
bim exemptes de variantes
1,8
c'est terminé pour défendre ça si tu
fais pub tu perds ton fouet si tu fais
ça bon bien devoir fourcade gagne et ça
donne un seul coin c'est très rare de
voir la fed à main
peut rester
comme deux scans 3 je crois
dépité le
monde vous savez surtout d'être là ah
bah oui il ya un monde bien grand monde
faites donc la veste est dit la messe
est dite mais sauf que tu dois jeu
jusqu'au bout mais c'est sûr que ça
allait sous la halle à elle c'est sûr vu
le niveau de jeu c'est sûr en fait
après mes pauses c'est fou quand il va
gagner sans même avoir une pression
ouais
personne n'est inquiet du tout
non là c'est vraiment la voie royale
c'est vraiment
royal
très vite une erreur
bassirou 5
donc j'en fais le titre abbaoui caspar
par exemple fischer aussi
pichard le plus marquant
fut il a refusé mais il a joué d'une
manière jeu sous une autre fédération
quoi qu'il a lui même créée
mais est très rare du coup
complexe
ce que serait pas l'heure de la pause
fab au bruit petite pause petite pause
on revient
cinq minutes samedi minutes peut-être à
est de retour 1 reste la politique des
chaises vides d'échiquier ville les
commentaires vide et donc la victoire de
radjabov contre contre ding
il a trouvé le gouffre f4 qui fait très
mal c'est vraiment qu'on avait montré
juste auparavant
qui attaquaient la tour c'est la tour
bouge assez par des loups satour décale
elle se fait manger terrible et si on
prend dame prend bien la toile à nouveau
attaqué il ya le cavadee qui va
débarquer la houle a toussoté explosion
au cours d'un victoires en 26 coups donc
de radjabov oh oui on va aller voir
revoir des joueurs ici duda contre irujo
rendez vous
non mais là qui s'est passé plus fous ou
5 la dame a bougé a été attaqué le cas
d'attaqué il a reculé peut-être ici
c'est mieux bon
roi h un cachet très bien logique utile
déblayent la colonne s'en lavent cette
diagonale ce mécène cases blanches
beaucoup moins fort droite huit tours
j'ai deux et on en est là
plutôt mieux plutôt mieux pour pour duda
et puis on verra comment ça quand ça
avance
4 maintenait les qualités wave a priori
tu vas enfin s'en vont défier cool je
tiens un petit air 4 kg 6 après s'il l'a
pas fait il a vu un truc qui lui
déplaisait je sais pas 3 il s'est quand
même pas une partie de très bonne
qualité
peut pas en dire moins quoi
et donc à fuir ou de jouer la 19éme
compte 17 il leur reste du coup ça va
c'est pas un grand programme note
rapporte que l'on a c'est fini non
d'ailleurs c'est la seule partie normale
je trouve de la journée sajoo rapporte
plutôt pas mal avec les mondiaux c'est
de mettre un peu la pression
bon après on fait une partie normale
celle là
on vient quand même ici sur la partie
d'un contingent français
torbey 8
ben écoute il s'en va sur une colonne
ouverte il veut peut-être rentrer à un
moment ou à un autre ici ou là
après sa menace pas grand chose parce
qu'on peut toujours couvrir la première
rangée le cas échéant que pas de grand
problème pour
pour 12 ha
ça peut faire plein de coups différents
mais peut-être tour f3 pour se placer
sur l'accolade mettre une pression ici à
l'énorme aucun intérêt à échanger une
tour contre une tour c'est le théorème
de houle sanderson dont on parle depuis
depuis plusieurs jours depuis plusieurs
semaines depuis plusieurs années
quand il ya deux tours contre une ou qui
a deux qui avait dans un coin dans
l'autre on veut pas voir disparaître une
sorte de pièce voilà donc là on pourra y
est d'échanger leur seul tour
tomber trois jouets duda qui réfléchit
ding ding a perdu est perdu
geithner pour les normes suis pas sûr
qu'il ait envie d'aller chercher le nul
à grenoble c'est pas sûr c'est une
qualité de moins c'est un roi un peu
dans les courants d'air le fou il est
pas mal donc c'est pas simple à tenir
pour mémoire je pense que là tu demandes
à ahfir au jaï te dis ouais nul je suis
assez content d'aller la chercher quoi
là je n'ai pas le goût d'aujourd'hui
mort mais dont il jouissait berlinoise
est né pourra répéter une partie qu'on a
déjà vu des centaines de fois un le
fameux d'un mac adam des quatre dans la
berlinoise
salut naruto
mais un commentaire pour la première
fois dans le chat la bienvenue ça va ça
va
donc
oui avec cette défaite de ding sa acte
quand même la qualif de fin la victoire
de données peau qui as deux parties à
jouer la 2.1 entier d' avance donc
demain ça m'étonnerait grandement que
eding
car on n'a qu'à puisse faire deux sur
deux pour finir et quand bien même il
faudrait que les peaux face 012 sont
posés
contre duda et rapporte normalement ça
va je pense qu'il finira par deux nuls
c'est tout ce qu'il veut faire enfin
rapportent ils jouent c'est parti donc
qui sait apporter capable de tout
juste
juste pense n'est peau l'année dernière
il est perdu la dernière ronde sans
enjeu contre d'inga peut-être cette fois
bas il va il va mieux gérer ça et même
finir carrément invaincus dans ces
candidats ce sera un beau challenge pour
lui
même s'il s'en fout mais il peut au
moins se fixer sa et se dire ok je vais
faire ça en plus par rapport à la
dernière fois et peut-être que ça va
amener le le truc pour être champion du
monde
trois ministres refusent de jouer ou ses
paroles en l'air bon c'est pas moi je
pense qu'il va jouer mais
apprécie pas il veut pas je suis pas
dans sa tête je pas dans son staff dans
son entourage
il fait comme comme il le sent
si je vous passe racaille ou quelqu'un
d'autre qui jouera
puisqu'ils jouent ils jouent
en même temps là nul entre d'accueil
menée pendant huit minutes une minute
chrono je peux vous remonterez cette
partie si votre intéressé par par cette
petite nul
elle est où
je vois même pas
niveau n'a qu'à appeler la voilà cette
partie là donc que 4,5 kireev trois
quines six espagnols
berlinoise de naka comme d'hab et les
pots en fait il va jouer les rendre de
nul ici bon la finale ça après france et
6 qui ont consisté prendre 5 lui la
prière est donc il est ce le fut en
prise avec les prix il fait à quatre ils
vont fermer le cavalier ils l'enferment
d'ailleurs il n'a pas de gaz donc je
vais noir la meilleure option c'est de
le rendre ici vous bouffe et puis il
faut que les draps finissent le
développement donc ils font ça pour se
dire bah voila je vais sortir mon fou je
suis là je vais rocqué et ses jeux de
chasse et la dame blanche de fond prises
en passant
bad as me rends obligé parce que s'il
faut prendre dame pranger 7 6 puis on
prend une structure pourri balle et
blanc veulent pas rentrer en finale de
la perche où ils font échec impossible
de couvrir comme ça il ya dame prend ici
vous êtes sava
façon on va se prendre des tempos détour
un grand pêche le rock etc voire des
fous g5 et clouage d'un me 6 plus
logique on revient donc lui peut
toujours pas sortir il y aura sa même je
le fous des sept grands draps que c'est
pas une idée parce qu'il ya sept ans
l'air donc le meilleur coût des moeurs
dam des six hommes on revient au nul
voila donc c'était tout mais c'est nul
qu'on a déjà vu des dizaines et des
dizaines de fois voilà voilà allez on
retourne sur le direct place au direct
priorité au direct entre duda et firoud
déjà
un peu une partie pour la cuillère de
bois quand même un
gros suspense est donc fois de jouer
fois deux coups de repli qui tient la
case b1 et et puis c'est à peu près tout
mais après on s'attend à ce que ça cool
is peut-être dame c4 à les viser par là
bas côté blanc
et résa qui réfléchit encore 16 minutes
pour jouer dix coups
ça va quand on maîtrise le tra bullet on
peut y arriver je vais dire qu en 16
minutes normalement ça de jouable mais
passé le plonger d'alireza à bail et il
est parti au combat le droit un g5
aujourd'hui
un bon gros tournoi je suis preneur je
connais pas trop le classement il paraît
que pau gatx corp a déjà fait un chrono
pas mal du tout
ce que les spécialistes des chronos ont
pris le maillot est-ce que ça roule
encore je sais pas là j'ai pas devant la
télé
dont j'ai trois puits sous les cèdres
attention attention aux fous attention
vous faut contrôler la casse g3 les amis
donc
pas trop là c'est pas le moment
mais dans un monde où le fou s'en va en
b2dix on ne sait pas pourquoi alors
rentré là va peut-être le théorème de
mazet tour ça c'est manger ou le sel et
deux tours sur la septième rangée on va
manger un sandwich très important
salua stouff
goguette chars troisième très très fort
d'un art second et victoire probable de
lampes parts ok eux
c'est qui ce land art connaît pas ce
qu'ils aient connu ce que
ça spécialiste des courses courtes
distances de puissance des contre la
montre
peut-être qu'elle va me dire
un way l'antarctique en tête c'est ouais
l'emportent en tête c'est l'information
fab de ce stream à 18h30 c est qui en
fait ouais mais c'est un bon rouleur jeu
chez les quick step non lampes art très
bon rouleur
alireza j'ai une fois deux je pensais à
ça je regarde un peu ton live j'ai fait
un petit tweet ada tout est magnifique
je devrais ce que les gens pensaient de
notre retransmission global parce que je
me dis en fait ils vont être tellement
déçus des deux derniers jours que
c'était le moment de poser question est
posée la question après puisque le ive
s'ils vont rester sur une très mauvaise
impression à la fin
omega pharma quick step quick step
ils ont rajouté des trucs devant
ou à plus d'une minute
la frime depuis sa blessure
jamais la guinée nord mobile sur ipad
d'apple the hell ou un truc comme ça
enfin c'est fini en fait c'est déjà beau
qui continue vélo d'ailleurs
oui oui
les chronos poukatch a déjà presque
appuyer le tour s'il ne chute pas bon il
ya qu une journée tours frérot enfin
puis je sais pas c'est quoi les écarts
sur 13 km il n'a pas pu mettre trois
minutes non plus mais si tu mets 30
secondes ça veut déjà dire que tu es
très légèrement mais bon tu peux va
plier le tour sur un prologue enfin faut
arrêter non mais demain tu prends une
bordure là sur le net pas le pont s'il
est demain ou après demain mais tu
prends une bordure tu peux prendre une
trentaine de minutes 1
pour lui le foot pour mettre deux
tours
vous n'hésitez pas allez sur mon twitter
chez qui a plus grand monde ici mais
j'ai mis quoi comme tweet femme je me
suis concentré mais vous avez aimé notre
couverture du droit des contrats dans sa
globalité pour interrogation en tout cas
on s'est bien amusé c'est vrai malgré un
tournoi qui a cruellement manqué de
suspense et de rythme c'est vrai
mais personne n'aurait pas assez un gars
qui répondent les moins suite which à
cause des résultats est fermé sur
youtube c'était le feu le format récap
rapide etc à paris plus dynamiques comme
si c'était parfait le tout très
rapidement beau travail pour lui la
bien-aimée
merci frérot bas il dit qu'il est pas
sur twitter si quand même
qui avait trahi par une bombe non mais
ça c'est sûr fable que demain enfin le
jour j'espère que ces dimanches pendant
les candidats mais c'est sur faut qu'on
regarde le moment ils sont sur le long
pond way est très long il part avec le
vent qui a soufflé le vent souffle sur
les plaines de la bretagne armoricaine
j'ai quitté bas qui est mon domaine
le tour arrive
le rythme était bien trop rapide en
effet des pauses plus longues entre les
parties était bienvenue aux kiwis
une suggestion suis davantage sur les
quatre partis des candidats par exemple
tous les quarts d'heure afin de suivre
le tournoi mieux ouais mais ça en fait
nous on suit le français un de base et
après on a suivi la tête du tournoi mais
je suis le français puis après on a
suivi les parties en jeu ouais normand
fait ça c'est pas nos idées mais le
problème c'est qu'il ya trop de gens qui
rompt pas suivre ah bah oui 90% des gens
regardent entre 5 et 15 minutes par
heure
parce qu'ils ont eu mal dès que je les
parties reconnaissent plus machin tu es
père quoi
même quand même quand des gens font des
vidéos des fois ils se font des
relations entre des partis ils se
ressemblent bon pas toujours donné on va
toujours est donc tu dis imagine les
amateurs dont quoi c'est
[Musique]
en fait ouais pourront plus bien avertis
bien attentif ça peut très bien marcher
être intéressant mais ça remet pour la
globalité vaut mieux ce focus sur une
partie tentant dé voir mais alors quand
on a vu les gens wise s'est déjà des
gens qui suivent vraiment les échecs
convoi qui suivent cinq à dix minutes
par heure et les gens qui suit vraiment
où le tous les partis de long en large
en travers ça représente quoi ça
représente 1% du public 0,1 je sais pas
mais c'est pas énorme
achetez cadeaux très heureux je suis
très bien les ports de bois merci
le soin chez pour le temps elle a
toujours pas assez pour la diffusion
parce que c'est enfin c'est bien écrit
enfin si tu lis vous avez aimé notre
couverture du thon à des candidats c'est
notre couverture cette ouverture c'est
écrit en fait
ça je crois qu'on ne peut pas grand
chose j'essaierai pacéré des belles
parties des mauges parti
alors tu as tout ce qui nous a écrit
d'heure il a changé son pseudo il a bien
mis ce tournoi c'est son anniversaire
d'air aujourd'hui très propre avec des
invités de marque dommage que le tour
n'était pas à la hauteur de la
couverture
saitama et là bas
michel lui a bien expliqué qui était la
patronne quand même franchement très
cool cette année entre les formats
express qui permet de comprendre
rapidement ce qui s'est passé et les
formats longs qui était pas trop long 20
minutes j'ai trouvé que c'était parfait
et les lives switch toujours aux petits
oignons et était content domino hurlait
qui nous écrit yes j'ai beaucoup
apprécié et l'estrie mon bien-aimé
journée de boulot que j'écoutais en mode
radio je rejoins les avis positifs
sur le format analyse express puisse
imparti grand format au top du raïs a
beaucoup plu ce truc dont on leur fera
peut-être un pour les autres restent bas
le mélange de
nikos mini format au top super
animations des live malgré ce format
ennuyeux si leur buggy super qu'un début
avec vraiment beaucoup d'antennes et
plus d'intervenants qu'à l'accoutumée il
est content aussi
bon j'ai hâte quand même qu'on y était
c'était vraiment de la merde car non
mais attends ça va arriver olsen haider
qui nous écrit au vu du niveau de l'ehs
résumé express étaient pertinents on
apprécie vraiment votre taf et la grande
qualité de contenu qui est fourni cela
dit certains grands formats était
intéressant il aurait pu mériter d'être
plus poussées comme ce que fait mathieu
sur twitch paris mais j'ai déjà fait sur
twitter fait
comme j'ai déjà en fait il écrit sert
été vues plus poussées comme ce que fait
match sur twitter mais du coup c'est
nous qui payons mathieu pour qu'il le
fasse donc c'est très fun
mais oui ça pourrait t'aider survie se
modifie un peu d'ailleurs à tous ouais
mais bon après c'est beaucoup et là les
raisons le problème c'est l'algorithme
après il pas content archimède dis bravo
merci
c'est bien sauf un certain fabien elle
dit l'imposteur invité de marque aussi
bien que d'habitude je regardais
quasiment tous les live donc c'est que
ça devait être intéressant le nouveau
format de récap rapide associés à la
longue vidéo d'alice c'est vraiment top
les récap de match avant les stream sont
incroyables le mélange résumé rapide et
l'on était vraiment agréable à suivre
wef avait nulle mais ça va
voilà super cool super boulot comme
d'hab meilleur ce crime et cheikh où il
part c'est vous n'êtes pas responsable
du tournoi merci tu vois c'est cool
parce que des fois y'a des gens qui ne
répondrait le temps était vraiment
ennuyeux matin mais oui on n'y peut rien
dislike will meet a des gens qui font ça
c'est insupportable en fait ce que du
coup tout ça te permet pas de corriger
en live on rigole bien donc c'est
l'essentiel c'est le gars qui écrivait
le message négatif mix a invité de
marque aussi bien que d'habitude nanani
nanana sans vous saurez été très chiant
comme tournoi à auto prochain candidat
avec un modèle compétitif et un bureau à
son vrai niveau
qu'est-ce qu'on nous écrit encore juste
pour faire plaisir à fable c'était
vraiment de la merde non c'est pas mal
sauf des fois vous partez en live
pendant des plombes et que moi je viens
d'arriver ah oui mais oui ça c'est sûr
que si je viens d'arriver mais bon après
si non c'est vraiment top vous faites
d'un truc ennuyeux un moment intéressant
ben écoute merci à toi le mélange résumé
rapide et l'on était vraiment agréable à
suivre
on prend les gens étaient vraiment
contents
chalfant fort y arriver avec des potes
qui nous suivent depuis le maroc
jolin marocain beau pays à noter cet
intérieur ouais c'est pas de convient de
fini ce qu'on puisse y retourner
pour v nos amis marocains
deux saunas et l'ancien intérieur pour
les gens d'affaires des plombs lors qu
il veut fut gagnée oui et non en fait
ils jouent leur premier lot quand même
et puis dernière place peut-être pas
hyper en juin dernier du tournoi même se
changer en soi mais
pour l'ego quoi
vous avez créé ici hein c'est hyper
chiant à suivre comme tourments et
pourtant j'avais qu'une envie c'est de
vous entendre commenté pendant le taf ça
fait plaisir
on a fait ce qu'on a pu un global mans
s'est bien amusé après l'aller
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment dur mais
parce que là c'est quand on touche le
fond au niveau suspense et contenu ça
devient enfin compte tenu des partis ça
devient dur
c'était très cool d'avoir un focus sur
la partie la plus intéressante de la
ronde était content tout le monde est
content boycottez merci bien bon retour
et vous parle pas efforts investis à ce
que les résultats qui n'ont pas amené
autant de bure que la dernière fois a
été frustrant non pas du tout
franchement non parce qu'on le sait en
fait c'est des choses qu'on maîtrise pas
donc on a faim moi personnellement j'ai
arrêté de me frustrer en fait ce que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure on n'a pas
le contrôle on sait qu'ils tuent les
échecs mise à part faudra un coup de bol
un moment donné qu'un mécène ou le
donnait toujours aux mêmes et de refaire
un énième bild qu'il décide finalement
de nous appeler d'arrêter de mettre de
l'argent par les fenêtres mais peut-être
un jour qui sait
après ça doit être cool d'avoir assez
d'argent pour le balancer dans les
fenêtres quoi en fait si on gagne à
l'euromillions jeux d'argent pour la
faire on fait une vidéo comme ça le
mécénat dans les échecs ont franchi par
3 500 mille ans les as de 50 on le fout
on prévient monde allait bien et on dit
à l'ats
le médecin on les échecs jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on prend on envoie par la
fenêtre et a monté une millions 5e mieux
dépenser ce serait quand même mieux y
avait des gens qu'il est qu'il gagnerait
bon du coup vous pourrez venir au stade
à sainté avant notre équipe au que oui
regardez vos matches ce serait trop beau
titularise débat qui attaquent quand
même
mais c'est lors de ce type mais je
connais ouais
j'ai entendu parler mais bon enfin 50000
euros ça nous suffit pas à quoi faut pas
acheter c'est ça
le problème
bonsoir oui je suis preneur c'est quoi
ce soir serait anticipons d'état un
livre comme ça il faut trouver un trésor
est barré par un indice dans le livre
est magnifique
tu vois que j'ai jamais joué au foot on
fait
enfin je veux contrats écrits ou quoi
mais on la jouera le mieux serait
gardien
rémy attaquant et sinon je serais plus
vu derrière leurs centrales ou quoi mais
gold j'aime bien fait face et pas juste
pour pas de sherbrooke les pieds c'est
que j'étais c'était mon meilleur poste
de loin j'ai des bons réflexes en photo
et galata vitesse un
gala ta vitesse
le feu dans des vrais cage ces packs du
réflexe programme de l'impulsion
foot en salle ou quoi jeter show gaulois
et a du coup est ce qu'on achète
bordeaux aussi vous faire plaisir à quoi
on est haut dans le mouvement en deux
clubs ah non
je ferai pas tout faire ce sera un
concurrent mais si on remonte après tête
on pourra les aider enfin un club filial
mais là dans leur revers à défaut ouais
voilà on croise comme ça mais la fera
dès la première année un séminaire dur
après si on peut sauver bordeaux recevra
bordeaux aussi club amiens d'ailleurs
mais c'est bon parce que si on gagne on
va vraiment le faire sécher ses
crevettes on ne rigole pas du tout
favoris mais nous on est très sérieux en
fait le truc scoré qu'une chanson sans
tromperie exactement mais en a cinq
chances sur 100 sont allés en un éclair
imagine-toi être précis et mais en fait
on a vraiment le faire enfin c'est à
dire que papa pas
les présidents et doivent suez quand
même et je suis frustré il faut pas que
les conquêtes quoi
voilà c'est fini
mais moins un poste ah oui c'est vrai tu
le baron fou ou lotus rallier droit
je pense qu être adjoint pour adjoint
des nuls j'en ai besoin de faire un
match nul à le baron qui va être
conseiller quoi vous êtes pour voulu
mettre des actions b seul face aux cages
cage vide comment tu rates quoi faire
patte quoi je sais pas comment mais
il va trouver au moins aujourd'hui il a
un peu d' attaques possibles sur j'ai
l'impression qu'il fait une partie
exceptionnelle sur
vraiment beaucoup d' attaque là bas mais
bon c'est vrai que si les blancs jouent
mal tu sait jamais c'est le roman mais
sur un jeu normal des blancs non
comme c'est beau
chat envie qu'on gagne à l'euromillions
quand ils veulent eux s'est arc et c'est
ce à quoi c'est un bel arc
par rapport à hier où avant-hier way par
rapport à du caca
c'est un peu plus solide que
l'intensité de la diarrhée un peu baissé
quoi
chez ruquier convaincu d'être à +3 là je
crois qu'il fait une grosse partie de
merde aussi tout un après c'est
peut-être juste pas facile en pratique
st oui mais bon on n'est pas leur place
ouaip on a pas on n'a pas très envie non
plus le temps
et vous savez pour être en mesure
d'apprécier
borand il faut aussi s'en taper quelques
de bien merdique et c'est pareil pour un
tournant et police certains de bien
verdict pour en apprécier d'autres
apprécié la white eu à apprécier
dimanche et lundi au chiva apprécié way
[Rires]
après c'est vrai qu'avec les déchets
qu'on a bien l'habitude draps sont bien
pourri on est on est bien prêt apprécié
un truc c'est
quelqu'un qui est je rejoins le
nouvelles réponses excellentissime
flemme d'argumenter vous savez pourquoi
vos formats sont parfaits pour commenter
un tel événement je ne sais même pas
comment vous pouvez améliorer ça c'est
sympa très bonne idée l'analyse rapide
ça m'a permis de me mettre à niveau en
rentrant du boulot merci à tous les
intervenants
cherchez dernier moi ce que je retiens
c'est le fond tadic à roue pas de
suspense mais c'était cool à suivre
beaux staffs et vous appréciez suivre je
vais tenter une critique constructive
j'ai trouvé les analyses en live parfois
un peu accès ce que dit l'ordi j'aurais
bien aimé un peu plus de mise en avant
des principes de jeu après c'est un peu
davantage de life aussi souvent c'est ça
le problème
voilà après c'était les mêmes les mêmes
commentaires
n'ont pas cette histoire de regarder
l'ordi ou pop en live
mais il ya les deux écoles en fait ouais
mais si tu regardes pas tu peux plus
commenter de manière dynamique parce
qu'en fait tu te perds long des
variantes tu dois te corriger ensuite
concentré tu peux plus parler en fait
mais dit non mais je sais ne peut pas
faire les deux en même temps
attention il maquille on discute pas
leur dis
ouais ça te faut quand même que des
radars dits tout le monde ça j'ai vu ça
des lives de joie qui te dis non droite
avec l'ordi et c'est que la ligne numéro
un c'est terrible
mais ok et enfin j'ai les critiques par
ils sont vraiment obligé de le faire
mais c'est ridicule quand tu le sais que
dire tu le dis comme ça peut être des
grands maîtres très fort d'ailleurs peu
importe mais c'est magnifique où il ne
regarde vraiment pas l'horizon à tous
qui sont regardés c'était la première
ligne c'est exceptionnel
foutage de gueule sur 10
du coup cette devions pour la qualité à
s'adapter ya peut-être là tenir bon a
priori vallat terrain
et tu peux pas vraiment commenter sans
ordi voilà je crois que ça toi fort est
bon pour un nul mais je crois qu'en fait
il ya eu les deux mille paysans peuvent
plus en fait c'est une commune et
pourquoi oui oui as tu fais pas
exprès dit quoi
d'ailleurs c'est plus flou qui va jouer
pour le gain quelque part après kg 3 tu
verras avions de plus on obligatoirement
passer 3g de il y aura tourbe et de on
parle x 2
en tension ambiants rive droite va
changer fou des quatre sets ça la partie
en fait 7 kg 3 roger deux tours b de
tours f2 mais ça va être sa prise prise
food et 4,3 g iii fou pranger 1 et puis
à 4
ouais ça c'est
pedro il va peut-être la jouer firoud
quand même une petite heure ou deux
quand même
voilà non tu dois mettre laurent c2 et
attendre en fait faut que le roi bloc le
pion et que le fou protège les pions ça
peut être trop dur ben là c'est vraiment
facile
ok puis monde
rapporte caruana pour finir cette
journée champagne ouais complètement fab
g3 joué les trois commandes de contrôle
du train prendra bien repartir pour une
heure chacun temps de bien jouer les
finales
famille qui d'un coup
alors mieux là ça va jouer un petit
moment ça encore fab mais bon on pourra
faire une petite pause une nouvelle fois
pour bien souffler après le 40e
on vous attend rejet de
l'étranger 3 à bien faire annuler en
force aussi ouais avant de laisser les
tours sur
la fin arrive
enfin laudren tu sais que tu sais que tu
fais nul quoi
marrant ne pas avoir réussi à pousser ça
quand même rien poussée du tout
d'ailleurs d'après l'ordi et notre nul
mais qui m'a l'air plus alambiqués ses
échecs or voilà on a [ __ ]
prise tour la menace matt
jean roy la tour la hâte avec le fou
qui doit simple la défense de ça et du
coup les noirs doivent dois te faire des
échecs
être si tu montes angers 4 il trophée
cheikh là où
roger 5 avoir cavaliers ses
atours des quatre cavaliers leucate
f5 quoi tu feras quelque part échec je
conviens vas-y autour des 4 faut faire
même histoire des cartes en fait juste
et comme tu touches plus le cavalier
c'est bon j'ai de temps de jeu moi je
pense à eux je pense à toi f2 à coup sûr
mais bon peut-être qu'il a vu l'autre
truc sa mère très bizarre l'autre et ça
fait nul à priori
on va encore une partie bien longue
qui décourage absolument fab
basque
lab
favier malouet je crois bien jeu comme
pam
paramètre là est vraiment
ma vie n'est pas bien à la fin mai mais
c'est vrai que
c'est des parties normalement tu
regrettes
des partis qui regarde quoi bon avoir
des résultats à la fin tu as ton fils
ton rêve de what u clic comme ça et oui
chères pas trop à comprendre audio
guidée loin à weill a regagné 1 banuls
les photos proposées à travers tu avais
la variante très bon ça c'est fait face
nuls de charles finul ça ça ne s'efface
et n'importe qui ferait
ça par contre ça rajoute un long moment
j'ai passé gagnon nul sa
flemme fabre attend la fin du set note
va faire une pause ouais parce qu'ils
vont réfléchir à ce qui va se passer ça
ait changé et ça valait guère espion est
à quatre points d'un côté de l'ach
passait de l'autre
alors on connaît les trois contre trois
à quatre contre trois structures
bizarres des pions doubler en 5
et on va attendre le 40e de fabi qui va
être tour h 2 c'est sûr et on va partir
en pause sûr à 100% a aucun risque et là
ils vont se lever il va rien se passer
pendant pendant des plombes ça elle va
jouer longtemps oui allez bon bah on va
passer une belle soirée ensemble a tout
de suite
remet attend enfin avant de partir on la
jouera mais la vidéo comme ça vous allez
voir la lisière h demain et l'autre
chiot se passera rien streiff avait
peut-être que si là il signe aussi vu
commettre l'échiquier de way au pire je
reviendrai mais attend on peut attendre
là ils peuvent s'ils temps ils vont pas
signé
non mais c'est un croate de réfléchir la
recherche fait nul en boulettes enfin je
me suis mis le pion à 4 gérer avec le
roi fin j'avais étudié même pas besoin
de temps en fait pour faire nul là je
comprends pas
ah si c'est signé ah
non mais j'hallucine est ce que c'est
vraiment très très simple on belette
1,20 us travel je sais quoi faire un
prénom après bon bah oui tu mets le pion
à 4 laurence et de et attend
qu'ils y discute
évidemment duda c'est qu'il a raté
quelque chose
il fallait pas croire que 2016 d'un coup
revue lactique de quoi que ce soit tu
faisais roi h1 et c'était tout c'était
de lentilles prophylaxie
allez on va vous laisser sur la cam de
la dernière saison ce qui évite de
magnifiques et on la vide et n'ouvre
profit charroi la chaire ouanna qui est
là avec les pièces noires entre
cherouana avec les pièces blanches aussi
cher ouanna qui se battent cher porte
cher porte sur ce les gars à tout à tout
on
deux parties et il ya eu quelques coups
de jouer donc depuis le 40e alors ils
n'ont pas été nombreux mais rapporte à
jouer un coup vous trouve logique il a
fait des quatre pour éliminer un pion on
sait que quand on défend dans des
finales moi y'a deux pions peut on se
rapproche de la nouvelle le nombre des
quatre mouvements bouffe et il a fait
autour des 6
l'attendait vite ça l'est aussi pour
aller là-bas mais tant déçu j'aime bien
parce que ça enfin contrôler ces cases
de la wii à la flèche on ne doit pas
sortir par ici ça touche le pion ça
c'est pas énorme s'agencer aidant les
adore avril à tour daniel pion ils
pourront pas et donc s'ils font un truc
comme échec et puis on pousse les blancs
mettront à tour daniel pion toujours
très bien placé pour
pour l'arrêter donc a priori
priori être à peu près nulle cette
finale mais je lui de chez qui un peu
chéquier et on va on va voir ce qu'on
dit la turbine mais mon avis c'est que
normalement ça se tient bien on va pas
être trop problématique
pour richard
autant compte quatre chalets pas trop me
soit 1 3 contre 3 la ville
ça fait juste nul tranquille
sans nom sans trop de problème
d'ailleurs
mais bon je vais aller lettres sur
l'ordi flot d'annoncés drouot ouais je
pense que c'est nul
il ya là bas c'est fini toutes les
autres parties se sont terminées
une nulle de dépôt nul de fuir ou de la
candidat nul non victoire de
radjabov contre
contre qui jouait radjabov il a battu
ding a battu ding c'est un peu la
surprise du jour en plus ils avaient les
pièces
ils avaient les pièces
noires radjabov donc gagné canard
funding c'est pas tous les jours est
donc grand voile et du coup pour la
seconde place il ya eu un resserrement
et un haga qui est revenu
j'ai changé la cam je m'étrangle comme
ça hop y en a qu à qui est revenu à
hauteur de ding et fabiano bas qui
reviendra un demi point là avec cette
nuit mais qui se profile si par miracle
ils gagnèrent mais carrément ex-aequo
mais bon a priori
ça va faire une donc donc voilà on va
l'écouter ce problème c'est que ça
risque de durer longtemps s'ils vont
beaucoup de temps la pendule et que
fabiano a aucune raison d'accepter même
si vite c'est lui qui a besoin de plus
il va il va la faire traîner et on peut
pas lui en vouloir moi j'aimerais bien
que ça est fini c'est et avoir une
soirée tranquille mais
en tant que compétiteur je comprends ce
qui fait
moi de mon côté j'aurai bien mais perd
au salon fait nul chao ont fait devenu
rapide et deux dernières rondes on se
quitte tous vos amis tout va bien
mais bon
on verra
sa baisse qui peuvent parfois il dit
bonjour on est d'accord que le gagnant
des candidats alors vous êtes champion
du monde pour le titre voilà c'est la
règle après là on a un cas particulier
cette année c'est que peut-être le
champion du monde en titre magnus
carlsen a annoncé qu'il ne jouerait pas
le match c'est pas fillon jack qui
viennent le tournoi et ça sera pas fil
rouge accueillera le tournoi ça c'est un
fait donc donc on verra sa décision dans
ce qui restera le premier ce tournoi
contre le second mais la règle de base
l'intérêt du temps à des candidats
depuis toujours c'est que le vainqueur
des candidats va jouer ou le champion du
monde donc c'est ça la règle tout à fait
prêt si le mec veut pas garder son titre
il fait ce qu'il veut on peut pas le
forcer la foire de force sur l'échiquier
combard qu'on devrait quoi
on a le choper en la tâche du chatterton
joue quoi
ce que le droit de refuser il a tous les
droits m'essayer refusent d'y perdre son
titre
il n'y a pas le droit de refuser de
garder le titre ça évidemment
alors b sinko été jouée
par fabiano a un coût qui va pas changer
grand chose je pensais que l'élan
jeffrey b 4 mois pour
pour bloquer cette expansion
tout simplement
parce que les blancs
on va dire le scénario qui va se passer
un jour c'est que la torah se retrouver
là bas derrière et et noir pourraient
tenter de ramener le roi ici pour aider
le pion une fois qu'il sera là et la
tour ici
donc il faut que les blancs pendant ce
temps et le temps d'aller faire un peu
de contre jeu et si tu laisses faire ça
aulnoye tout premiers chefs d'état le
roi ici tu es un peu cloisonné ne peut
pas sortir fin de contrat je donc si tu
fais ça tu as toujours des passages pour
ton roi par ici pour plus tard donc tu
feras pas bloquer cette avance déjà un
pion s'il ya une course un jour
moi j'aime bien par principe je le
ferais quoi
richard l'a fait ça me semble très
logique
semble très logique
et
net's abbès qui demande ça serait qui du
coup le premier de leur premier set
nepomniachi et le second passage entre
hikaru nakamura et ding voir caruana
peut-être
a priori c'est ça le
truc
vraiment aimé voir un radjabov quitte
une remontée de où il seconde
[Musique]
il n'est pas enterré pour cette course
là
il fallait y sera comme caruana en fait
dire à
naka eding avec 6 points et demi et un
demi point derrière il faudrait 2 avec
naka et et radja
donc voilà
parce que
nous y voilà ce fait nul tiens je te
retrouves micro
voilà ses news
ah oui c'est nul de chez nul en fait or
ce serait serré que taylor bon regarder
patron était comme ça on se dira tiens
quatre contes théâtre machin est vrai
que le coût des quatre canetons
pourquoi leur dit non à ces unions
visuellement jusqu'en mai prochain ça va
monter plus vert et puis va comprendre
eh ouais parce que ça sent 7 nuls facile
en fait
paradis dont ils nous disent a alors dit
je suis ses coûts
bon bah non et la semaine dernière comme
dis plus de 50
est
fait on coud
h 2
les images de la gueule du monde
ouais c'est vraiment nul ça
en fait on leur dit crack
commence à comprendre
bah c'est le problème en fait un bond en
fr c'est que les noirs pour gagner ils
ont bien enlevé sept tours pour faire
dame donc s'ils en avaient la tour on va
juste après le pion ils ont besoin du
roi ici pour défendre bon et puis
pendant qu'ils débarquent et bombe un
moment quand on veut on va dire oui bon
maintenant tu défends tu peux enlever la
tour on va juste faire des échecs animé
quelque chose de rond 92 personnes et
s'il va jusqu en c1 peut-être
je comprends je comprends pas moi-même
non mais non j'en attends
ton
[Musique]
vas-y en b1 j'attends résidant à
tu vas te la torah
dont 26 et 3 mais je n'aime pas ce que
j'ai besoin de
trouver un
là j'ai fait le meilleur on a laissé
faire de
plus j'ai fait recette rudd 3-2 et géant
va lire et écrire ok bon bah on va
embêter de joué-lès-tours h4 il a fait
un petit b 3
on va pas perdre son âme et de m
ça peut durer encore deux heures mais il
n'y a aucune chance de gagner non je
crois qu'ils sont bien cliqué un peu
vite je pense que les deux savent
et savent que c'est pas dur à faire quoi
merci harness pour les cinq sacs du coup
s'il en est
ouais non non c'est nul les deux ça ça
pourrait terminer vite fab on espère
quand même un
petit coup de grâce dans la journée d'un
jusqu'à 22h suivre sur ça
c'est pas du terminal haut c'est nul à
12h
du ladhof fassilado
on va voir là ils vont clic vite
ça va quand ça nous fera une journée
j'ai envie de dire heureusement qui a
passé deux parties qui dure jusqu'à 22
heures pour rien des noces à 20h
vraiment dernier quart en quoi on peut
faire notre petit récap rapide aller
dîner oui
ça va faire plaisir fait quoi pizza on
avait une idée venir mais spezza ça va
très bien c'est que notre idée
a le coréen à magnifique au plan b lille
mais bon voilà 22 heures ouais mais un
son bien au fait si même s'ils finissent
à 20 heures on fait le récap vite et on
vit une vie vite vite vite vite
l'express
ah oui oh bah là il faut il faut cliquer
un relais familles mais manger un bon
coréen à briennon barbecue cauteleuse
quoi tu as eu la belle idée la fab
propose nul à il est bon ce coréen en
plus oui j'espère qu'il n'est pas fermée
on n'a pas vérifié hier s'ils étaient
fermés note des dates aléatoire mais je
crois que c'était juin non mais là quand
même c'est un vendredi quoi
ah ouais ces embellies
patou qui composent ils vivent pas à
vous maintenant ewen on aimerait bien
mais en fait on peut pas on doit
attendre la fin quoi
on décide pas
en ukraine je paye
rhein sh pas
il faut des marchés c'est pas qu'on en a
rien à faire en fait c'est que la partie
n'a pas d'intérêt pour le classement
quasiment fin et en plus ça fait nul
puis ça fait nul
c'est vraiment ça doublement aucun
intérêt en fait enfin la journée avec
globalement aucun intérêt du moment qu
ging a été perdant en fait fin ils
annulent denat kaeding perdants après
une heure de jeu en fait il y avait déjà
plus d'intérêt après 1h
familles qui cherchent
hamon regardez ça jusqu'à 22 heures non
la question c'est ce qu'on préfère ne
pas manger ce soir où regarder ça
jusqu'à 22 heures or si on disait ça
s'arrête maintenant
est libre mais tu peux pas dîné
août attendant regardez ça et une étoile
droit de manger des ouais
je vais te manger quand même donc tu
regardes heures et jusqu'à 22 heures au
pire je fais les yeux fermés j'ai pas
manquer si on me disait obligé demain tu
peux manger mais que du syntagme
au tattoo fini maintenant quoi et tu
fais c'est un taiwo regarde boys and
bike
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup michel va sauver des
questions comme ça est-ce que je vais je
me déplaçais du syntagme je reste bien
la longe et où je suis
compliqué
les douze canard
enfin fait faire des brand moules sont
eux faire suivre toute ta vie par 12
canard
rose c'est chiant après l'es12 canard
c'est ça me dérange pas quoi tu
t'habitues quoi pouvait bien ça donne
c'est la famille kw afin d'en faire un
petit câlin bien sûr ils vivent moins
longtemps que toi
d'autre qu' il y autant sphinx et des
canards magic
s écart matrix est différent
si je me rends le sénat aujourd'hui
gardé les mêmes quoi ces canards en
belgique on va dire
tu aimerais pas enterrer des canards non
il faut niveau de claudine non mais ça
dort les canadiens
ils sont tranquilles nous mettre leur
bec dans l'eau j'en connais j'ai eu des
oies enfin je connais très bien
amicaux ils sont cool quoi l'abri quand
ils se réveillent soit ils peuvent
dormir sur l'eau ouais je sais
mais il souhaite toujours
voir les plumes quoi bon en harmonie
avec les canards n'est pas trop là alors
si j'ai des brand mousse
je peux plus cliqués quoi déjà enfin un
problème sa loi cliquez même pour manger
une glace comment je fais quoi enfin
être un inconnu qui passe
donc non non non
ça avoir cliqué
[Musique]
florent baki
sa carrière jo flambe à qui ouais jamais
quitté un kit et sans rompre
je pense que je ferais droit à trois
essais 4 en fait
ben et pour l'envoyer ans estime qu au
moins à vie si je bouffe l'option
peut-être qu'on remarque
mais après et
pour garder croître
il va cliquer par là non
le clic et sa clique et par ici
vous fait ça et on les professions de
meilleures options et puis
battre grèce le mal à vouloir gagner
fait de faire droit 3-0 ritchie
on est obligé de rester jusqu'au on sera
obligé de commenter dimanche et lundi ce
qu'on n'aurait jamais fait normalement
on aurait arrêté de tourner en a déjà
mais c'est pas grave
vous pouvez me prendre
et liberté de pensée
liberté de cliquer c'est qu'on évite à
tout prendre
ap
jc mois une orange
vous pouvez tous bords n'aurait pas
gardé clic et florent vaki ouais mais
est-ce que ce qu'on me prend son canapé
à florent baky lembeye qui ne feraient
pas ma chaise gaming me prendre mais
prépa mais coupe ma souris la souris
mais mes livres mes livres de d'études
vous n'aurez pas ma liberté de cliquer
familleureux
savoir cliquez
contre un inconnu qui passe
ne laisser aucune trace
[Musique]
dick que pour le plus
d'argent qu'ils s'en prendraient à tout
prendre
et donner un take back
trop gentilles drogue
qu'est-ce qu'on se fait chier quand même
c'est
assez impressionnant
pas même l'espoir d'être pathé quoi
[Rires]
non
tu pourras vie n'en faut plus quoi votre
rigueur parce que c'est vraiment
toujours comme ça c'est vraiment c'est
très souvent de la merde est parti donc
c'est souvent la merde c'est pas
toujours toujours toujours mais c'est
souvent quand même primes s'élevant à
toi ça te rend plus qu'ils ajoutent en
plus de tout le reste on s'en passerait
bien quoi c'est vraiment vraiment hélas
ils veulent bien réfléchir on en a pour
deux heures
minimum
a reçu
ces mystiques en fait
l affaire de temps des trucs de merde
mais c'est quand même assez étonnant
que tu voudrais faire exprès et y
arriverais pas un truc aussi nul c'est
intéressant à jouer mais je jouais
à la pro a rapporté la partie cycle est
hélas tu vas de sa position comment il
est là
langage corporel donne pas une
excitation de
la sexy quand même temps on pourrait
s'excuser après complètement s'éclipser
personne ne vous dirai rien en fait on
pourrait laisser de live ouvert et juste
éclipsé mais bon on attend
mais bon comme ils ont pour rien en fait
j'espère viable selon près
c'est juste qu'il diffuse le tournoi
des accords avec la fidh pour les images
pour tout ça déjà c'est cool qu'ont eu
les images et tout ça donc je sais pas
c'est pas un souci
je pense qu'il peut faire échec échec
échec échec
ces 5 tu fais h3 je remets mon rang b 2
et là tu bouges plus
nous avons fait remettre
ça change rien serait joué b5 non mais
tu peux jamais de variations passées
nuls
franchement ça fait nul en force
je repars commente parce que si on
réussit je te bouffe ouais et on revient
h3 je viens h2 je viens y a pas déjà la
première way
rapport faire de se faire chier car on a
se fait ch et on se fait chier en fait
un les arbitres font chier le public se
fait chier
mais c'est globalement beaucoup de monde
se fait chier dans ce sens il ya quand
même pas grand monde qui joue des
tournois en partie longue
je connais peu de gens qui disent ah oui
canadien on va se taper une partie
longue ou enfin
temps des gens qui jouent un peu au foot
il faut un peu de vélo ou quoi il ya
beaucoup de gens juste qu'ils le font
loisirs là ce qu'ils font en loisir
un petit blitz invite oui mais faire ça
il ya perte même une rapide me faire ça
y'a personne qui fait en fait
c'est pas ce n'est pas amusant en fait
partie un bon petit repas quand même
après il est 15 heures de travail on
joue et puis tu te dit pas un mot
avatar tard encore là
je vous la même partie jusqu'à 22 heures
ça continue quoi
en tournoi à six mois mais a peu de gens
qui jouent en tournée aux échecs
merci agréable pour ton mais pour ton
message
avec une raclette et un échelon mieux
pourquoi pas ça mais là les ont pas la
raclette
tu oublies les interclubs n'y a pas
grand monde qui fait des interclubs
notre club je suis vraiment pour une
réforme et qui est plusieurs parties
dans la journée
ah bah oui c'est plus marrant c'est en
fait très souvent les interclubs à
petites divisions tu vas jouer il ya des
forfaits en face tu tapes la route vont
pas jouer super ou des fois ils te
mettent des débutants jusqu'aux être une
licence ne pas se prendre le moins et
les amendes et combien même ça joue bon
bah tu peux perdre vite refait la route
pour y inclure une partie très long tu
as entre 23 d'art chez toi alors que
s'il y avait je passais sur des équipes
de quatre ou même de 8 peu importe tu
compte quatre joueurs de l'équipe
adverse tu tournes un peu avant 4h dans
ta journée c'est fun ça je pense ça
c'est plus cool quoi en fait ce serait
marrant et donc
donc à tous niveaux déjà moi je passe
rapidement pour moi non mais admettons
que mon ma pause autre chose parce que
comme je suis censé enfin comme joue en
première division il faut décider oui ça
c'est pour les pros fermez la et
voudrait bien ça bon d'accord pas
admettons si on veut mais pour tout ce
qui est lié en dessous a plus amateurs
normands tu fais un truc fun qu'ils
soient simples à jouer quoi ah
ouais ils ont fait vrai
et on a un autre arbitre derrière c'est
plus le lard mitre femme qui avait son
épaule
et ben voila parfait une nulle signer
finalement faire pour avoir le temps de
manger j'aurai un peu de fair value mais
voilà on va le faire moi-même parce que
franchement sont fait direct
bam
sassard bon bah écoutez c'est une bonne
soirée demain c'est repos reposez vous
bien et dimanche on sera là pour suivre
l'étape du vent sur le pont quoi c'est
dimanche à cette étape va où sera là
lundi aussi donc vous inquiétez pas on
verra bien le vent soufflait allez bonne
soirée